okay
alright alright alright alright alright
mom oh I'm so tiny
yeah a little bit
my baby don't mess around because there's something else and then she told me so
black cats and then and then
but I know for sure
oh oh sorry you just caught me
warming up for my future karaoke stream
oh no I'm so embarrassed
I can't believe you caught me like that
oh um good morning
good evening and uh good afternoon
who's that going? who's that going?
on 4k bro
as if I didn't orchestrate that bye bye
okay she's in the ash kitchen voice again
hiya America hiya
good morning
uh I haven't add in front of the stream
no you shouldn't have I've told YouTube not to do this specifically
that's not right hold on hold it
fucking monetization
choose when mid rolls appear insert them manually
YouTube's taking the piss
because I haven't put ads on I don't put ads on on live streams
are they forcing ads on live streams there?
they better not be I'm gonna fart
I'm gonna do it okay
I get ads on my phone
um that'll be YouTube pocket in the full ad then
what did I just walk into?
I don't know
please don't think about me like that
okay got a bit of an update
Mercy's emotes approved I'm just waiting for the delivery so they could be thingied
there was two mistakes with Azur's emotes
so I had to pay an extra couple of dollars do's
but the sneaky little sneaker tins
they extended the delivery time by three weeks to fix two emotes
and they already have taken quite a while
so I need to wait until Mercy and Azur's batch of 10 are done
before I can order everyone else's missing slot emotes
is that my sense?
so I can't do anything yet
my hands are tied
my hands are tied okay
but not to be confused my hand can't
okay as for the updates again
bleeding hearts, reflins, both the user in the same club
I'll need to sleep after the stream
and then I will get the third audio up
my audio is beam of fur babacucation
and Azur's is landlord lips never felt so okay
who wrote that? it was me at the time
it was absolutely outrageous behaviour
honestly outrageous
is that doom music playing in the background?
but I hope not
there shouldn't be any music playing in the background
this is what plays in the background
but it's a bit sad
but anyway
got an update
me dad
me dad's officially
fucked off
nah it's true, papacuttle's is heading home
so
now I do have two more streams of shorter games
just so I can catch up on the ASMR I need to record
because I need to record about 3 hours worth of shit I'm missing
but the good news is
it lets me catch up on all my work
now I do have a message for your reflins
but I can't read it yet or I'm gonna cry
so I'll read it tomorrow
I can't read it today
or I'll greet my eyes out
I miss pap already
aww I miss him too I was so sad
both of us were like
I was like I didn't want to cry in front of him
as he was going
so I was like
so there's this fucking meme for this stupid thing
I don't know what it is
but the meme goes
be strong, Clarence be strong for mama
and that's what goes in my head
when I try and tell myself not to laugh
not to cry sorry
like to try and cheer me up
I can't remember what the meme is
but it's like be strong, Clarence be strong for mama
so he didn't see me cry
but as soon as like
I couldn't see him anymore
oh god I'm getting emotional
ok we're playing a little to the left today
which is a puzzle game ok
now as well no puzzle game
so it's my biggest enemy
because it requires IQ
that I do not possess
in any way shape or form
thank you GothMommyBee
for becoming a member
enjoy those emotions
I have four more on the way
I think there's four more slots
bye strong
be strong for the refling
it's a TISM game
oh god
isn't that a dodo meme
it's a pokemon meme
it's like a mash of a dodo
one of the dodo birds
it's wrong
yes oh my god you know it
now you got high IQ I can tell
yeah
hello
hello am I broken
have I crashed
hello
hello testing
hello hello
hello hello hello
bye am I crashed
what the fuck
my OBS was like red
red panic
red alert red alert set phasers
to eliminate
oh my god
what was that
don't do that again
you're stressing me out
did you guys like my short
where I was like hey this is how much
vtubers actually make
and I'm not just gonna dance around the question
wait hold on let me link it
right I'll give you that before we get into
I need to do the
I need to do the repromotional bit here
the red spies in the base legit honestly
best short yet
I got a short and then I asked the question
and I actually answered the question
in the short
oh my god
VTuber challenge complete
asked the question and actually
answered it in a short
oh let's go man
the numbers were
very impressive
right so some of you might not know this
I got a thousand dollar donation
completely anonymous
near request not an else attached
couldn't give life of a shit
just gives me a thousand dollars and pisses off like oh
so that's the truth but yeah
that's great short but the IRS jump
skewer is not appreciate
bro if you need to hold 30% back or the IRS
is literally ready to like
I'm gonna dick you
down like that
there you go
and it's for sure not sabotage
maybe from this one someone was like
remember that time you were worried about funding
gen 2 and I'm like
honestly
just off it you're making me blush
like real real
actually real okay let me just
slurp my tea
also nice to meet everyone
hi
thanks for joining for that first time
I'm strong enough
unfortunately I'm Scottish but
the good thing is it gives me frost resistance
so it's not bad
if you would like
to consider yourself
an enjoyer of me
you can refer to yourself
as a replay
or replay
when you came and you gave me a
kiss
I reached a round
and
you got a thousand dollar dono
what about Emmy's 400 dono
it's getting clipped and shipped
it's already been sent for editing purposes
so
identify as an ord
I am translucent with how pale I am
you can see my entire vascular
system at a glance
that's how pale I am
I literally have hues
of purple and blue thanks to
my veins that I am that pale
so I would consider myself a
Nord and the name of the Nord
I pray to the Lord you all get a taste
of my blade and my sword I'm taking on
what's that Emmy's
purple yes if you
have very translucent skin
veins can appear purple and I have
very almost purple esk under
my eyeballs and relay which means I'm
perfect for being a girl
oh my god that was a voice crack
voice crack
also we saw the ring fit stream
I assume you haven't seen sunlight in years how
dare you
he spoke nothing but the truth I'm
insulted by such words
and yet no true words were spoken in that
moment my goodness
you could probably put it to scripture that's
so truthful he was being in that moment
aww absolutely annihilated
honestly sun gets reflect
I can't go outside without fully closed
it'll be like
well it's winter right now so it doesn't
wait what's next
my wires
sorry if I seem like
fucking hyper I'm like
super sad inside but I'm really glad I get to
talk to you Evelyn I'd be a puddle
right now and I just
thought this game was gonna go shite because
it's a fucking puzzle game
it requires IQ
the beacons are lit have you slept
so I
stayed up last night
writing scripts for the girls
so
AC has a script
about scratching your back
because obviously she's a polar bear and she's got
claws right so
I
wrote a script about AC that she gives you like back
scratches in the middle of the night and she has
her sleepy voice on okay
and then I wrote one for
Mercy where it's Yandere
it gives you a haircut while she's tied you up
in your bed ASMR
it's the most bizarre thing I've ever written in my life
are you squiddin me right now
I'm fucking giggling away at myself over it
and then Azura's is a
dummy mummy
praises you in your sleep
ASMR I've not finished Azura's
but I'm about to
but I sent it to Mercy and Mercy's like oh
I actually wrote some stuff for myself
and then Azura was like oh I actually
got some stuff to do YouTube ASMR
with and I'm like
my daughters don't even need me
I'm being outsourced already
Tim Schottel thank you for the tip
love the new short your open book
just as open as my legs baby
well I tried
and it's very interesting to see the things
that people don't share you are amazing
thank you I appreciate it
yeah I
personally I have
problems being like this is what it looks like
behind the scenes because I think a lot of people
don't get the opportunity to really see
that which is why I want to be like
hey we might be a small
agency but I did put a bit
of thought behind you know
gets an exchange of services and
trying to earn my money you know
I might be shocking
but mummy
what is bigger your first month's paycheck
for beach ever are you
long what
I don't
I mean I'm technically
five inches
what is that
they're all grown up outsourced in the first
month honestly
I've got a collab with AC and Emmy
to write but so there's one
on Emmy's channel of her and AC
but I need to do it the other way
around and I think I want to do it
like Bratz give you a haircut
because I need to record new haircut sounds
well piss
what I'm so sorry that was my accent
let me try that again
thank you for becoming a member I'm so sorry
I said piss in your name there's not it's just
I just can't read properly
I'm so sorry I think I might do like
two Bratz cut your hair in the middle of the
night for Emmy and AC and they're whispering
to themselves about how mischievous
they both are and then you just get like
back like over the cheek
and then like kind of like the midnight
barber mean for the mighty bush if you've
ever seen that it's about a British
comedy yeah
but it's got to be
those units don't compare
you know what compares
me and you
I'm sorry
we missed up we gotta go but oh that's how I
should end it oh shit we missed up
we gotta go
I think strongy call me
I know it's okay it's a hard name
just say I just don't make it easy
oh my god can't believe you're not making it
easy for me
this is
this is my time joining a violer stream and I know this
is adult agency and I mean
very adult by adult I mean jerking my
pintas but I'm curious on whether or not
it's a nice and welcoming community as well
as the others yes it's
a misconception that we are literally
humping the screen 24-7 on youtube
nope that's that's not what we are
however I do love challenging
a bit of a misconception anyway
off to a conspiracy theory stream
hi I'm strongy I have
five other gen mates if I am not
your flavour please do check
them out they are a lot more nicer
sounding than me and have a better
train of thought if you like
yappers sheevy cotton bomb
is the one for you if you like
an absolutely adorable
yandere vibe
merci modiste is for you
if you are into the more forbidden
things in life my friend
oh boy do I have a girl for you
her name is emi bezu do not translate
that name you will get in trouble
and be put on a list okay
now if you like
a very close experience
and a little bit of
d-d-l-g
how you see snow paws is for you
and last but certainly not least
MUMMY MILKERS
azura duly
those are your choices
do with that what you will
she's also addicted to league I'm sorry
like like so
everyone needs a weakness okay
azuras just happens to be league of legends
everyone needs a little thingy
and me I'm just strongy cause
and unfortunately I'm Scottish
it's the best I got
right I'm gonna finish my honey tea and then we're gonna do
a little to the left
and then after that
hmm
I like this funny creature
this creature amuses me
you mean fortunately you're Scottish
I SHITE ME IN SCHOOL
yeah yes uh membership streams
also start up
not gonna lie
being addicted to league is a huge deal
like everyone needs a weakness
my weakness is like I'm literally
I'm not allowed to say that cause it will
worry you guys
I'm not allowed to say that
being British is your weakness
no that's probably what it is
I get considered British cause technically
you know United Kingdom, Scotland
however
yes
I'm not gonna lie
first agency I liked all the members
and I actually sit through the streams
so
obviously
the girls are free to discuss their PL
stuff but I've kinda said this
like everyone got picked cause I saw a bit
of myself in them
and I have a bias for the underdog
I don't give a shit
if you think that's a bad whatever
I like the underdog
obviously the only exception is kinda
me the Emmy if you want to get
takey spaky
but Emmy
Emmy
was I've said this before
Emmy was quite inquisitive during the interview stage
and she was like
asking how it would work behind the scenes
and she was very keen to start on something new
and I can completely
relate on a personal level
of being like I don't wanna do this shit
no more on my own like fuck it let's
let's do it
so yeah
this is definitely a yapping corporal on that
right and he gets started with the game
I have no idea how long this game takes
I am going to aim for like a two hour stream
and then I'll read
oh she be
okay I can't read it right
into she be
here I will admit I do miss the bunny
the bunny's coming home
she's coming to my house
and I'm coming all I'm sorry I'm not
oh we burp I'm so sorry
to that person that's new
we burp a lot all of us pretty much burp a lot
uh Azura should have
a new short up about burping if I'm not mistaken
hold on Azura Duley
I spent a ridiculous amount of money on the shorts
oh there it is
oh no it's Azura's milk shop
wait hold on let me
Azura got four shorts
and they finally came
they came we sent them
to an editor right
and then the editor went AFK for two weeks
so we had to send it to a new editor
and the new editor was like give us five days
and I'm like
Azura has literally no shorts please
please I'm begging that's
Azura's one and then she be
I think oh no she be's aren't out yet
she be's both got limited ads and I'll let bro
but yeah
Azura is so strong even in the shorts
think your dad went home too
and if so he made it home okay
and he's nice and safe
at all
I didn't want to see yesterday
I was came to try to hint being like
oh my dad is disappointed
about being here
I wasn't quite
I just I didn't want anyone being like
he is on this flight number let's
fucking yeah like no thank you
I saw what the big
I saw what the big bros did to me
and after I'd met you
you only
that's not very nice
do nice things
so I've seen from your lawyer siren
I am a siren that cannot sing
and because of that I use hypnosis
instead to control the will of men
me who has done one hypnosis stream
and nothing more but I'm working on it okay
I'm recording the pregnancy
it's more than I okay
are gonna get started
and deeply departed
a little to the left
a puzzle game
you know tell me
if the volume level
will be the judge of that
chapter one
home sweet home
can someone look up what the actual
time is this
okay we're in a hoose together we fling are you ready
it's a pudders
mr whiskers
oh wait
how much did I pay for this game
can I get a refund
right so this is pudders is
are you squiddin me right now
I don't know what the logic of this one is
stop
no
I don't say it by my teammates
I get embarrassed around them
I'm like
actual logic puzzle time
thank you tiny spiny
this one has two brain cells
and it's devoted to the legit
uhhhh
right black
what
all the marks the pencil marks
in the background I see it
I see it
the pencil marks in the background
here there's a hen I saw
it's still blinding first thing
in the morning that's why I didn't see it
okay it's still blinding
right okay connect the link
next thing
nope can't be there
can be there can't be there
that has to be the start
okay everyone move along one
yeah
my thumbnail is edith finch
a better no be
hold on hold on
no on that end it's a little
to the left
I'll just see it in 4k
I don't know why I actually got
copyright on the edith finch scene
I'm trying to edit it out
but it's like not
straightening you up
are you squidding me right now
tonight I won't be able to
watch stream so I will just leave this here
good stream mama
and fellow reeflings
please rest well
and thank you for the super chat
very generous
please rest well and enjoy yourself
and have a good time
please don't listen to that one so far
please have a nice afternoon or evening
would you accept a child on your
what channel
mods
mods you know what to do
what the fuck am I doing here
thank you mods appreciate you
oh we got a ding
we got a ding for the back one
they went on mercy's stream
there are so many say so
which of yours you can consume
no go play minecraft
no actually go play roblox
what the fuck am I doing
am I stacking them
oh I'm stacking them
I'm stacking them
oh my god we got there in the end
I feel
there's so many say so
yeah I'm here
mods literally got jumpscared
did they
thickness
no you're so thick
it can't be it has to be hey
did they do that to us
wait what
hey
no
oh
oh it was wait
excuse me where's my fill points
to me the thumb still looks like the last one
oh yeah for me it's correct
I'm not sure why
I will definitely
need to deal with that right now
cause people legit might be thinking
I somehow got stuck on edith
and I couldn't play it
that's strange
hold on
sorry
people don't click cause they think I got
it's got stuck in edith finch then
that's on me I guess
puzzles have one more solution
to get them all with the stars
oh god it's cause reading the title
is too hard right
oh right the stream
I thought you meant on the books I was like
right what are we looking at
oh don't hurt him now
okay we're kinda doing a leaning tower of
pizza but that's okay
look we love a good landmark
okay actually help me out let's go
oh piters hello piters
oh piters
do you want
to have good time
hi piters
oh you're taking it
why are you taking it
thank you for telling me
the stamp was underneath mr. piters
thank you
little kitty
it was pleasure meeting everyone
hope you all see you around
also I'm hoping you
don't judge me
I mean you should see my news short if you think
oh wait no that doesn't make sense
ignore that last sentence
I miss understood your message
what the
okay it's a grid of
four
okay
can't be that one
it's a grid of four
uh-huh
oh don't hurt him now
oh it's a signature
it's a grid of four oh nine
sorry I
the numbers come out correct
incorrectly
from my voice but in my head they're correct
oh there's leaves
one two five
uh
oh the claws right how many
there's five
berries that look like this
oh that's so smart I like this one
hold on sorry
I'm actually getting into this game I thought I was gonna be
resident sleeper but hold on a minute
I'm came to
I don't know this game's came out uh-huh
I don't know
I bet you as soon as I stop being able to do the
puzzles like right off the bat I'll be on one
I'll be like region I'll be like no I don't
I don't like this game anymore but right now
I'm actually doing really good so I'll take it
may I be satisfied
oh should I be really going oh
right
okay
three plus twelve
wait no what's the difference between
three and twelve nine
one two three
four five six seven eight nine
one two
wait plus nine is 30
okay
okay I can do it I can do it I can do it
um what are these
spinny things
um oh it's a star eight
oh no there's tons
how am I supposed to do this via logic
right the difference between one and ten
is nine so
nineteen
and then nineteen plus nine is
twenty eight
one two three four five six seven eight nine
okay and then
the red one is first
and the blue one is nice
the flower thirteen
take away four is
nine again
uh nine and thirteen
together make
twenty two
okay
and then
five comes after the
flower
okay okay don't hurt him now
and then after the flower is the yellow
don't hurt him now
don't hurt him with that logic now
don't don't hurt him now right and then
a gap between the yellow
and then it's the petal
gap between the yellow
oh my god I love that
I loved everything about that please more
oh my god
there's a fake sign to start a sign when doing it
correctly
is this hate
or am I making a picture
it kinda looks like hate
uh
uh huh oh yeah
don't hurt him now
let him get up let him get up
let him get up
uh huh uh huh
yeah
yep yep yep yep
okay that's not the answer
but that's okay
what happens if we did it
if we put
even Steven on the outside
going in
because then that middle book isn't odd
because it'll go in the middle because there's only one of it
oh
oh this is actually not a bad game
are you squeaking me right now
oh my god
alright
we just don't love me
if I had a wrinkly brain
thank you Kaidon for the super chat
we just don't love me if I had a wrinkly brain
reference
okay what's going on here
oh
we need to make them straight
wait
like that
oh
we're on Machu Picchu
I did it
oh my god wait a minute
I remember Vivi said
she didn't like this game
I got worried
now we're just
there we go right we're information fishing
bye
we're just information fishing
look
I like that the game
gives you a hint as well
like that ding
that audio cue
that you're doing the right thing
that's right give it to me
give me that audio cue
I'm looking for
oh yeah
you know you want to give it to me
give me that ding
ring my bell
I like the sticky paper noisy
and you want to make some sticky paper
no stop I'm not
I promise
what's going on here
right
we've got super sharp
maybe lint
uh you look wrong
colors
red and orange
and yellow and green
oh
okay
this shiny sticky noises
ASMR win
well I've got a lot of ASMR catch up on
hmm
I like to be quiet about it
we've got it
I have a plane ticket
first
first thing first
under view
I don't fold it
I feel like
oh
are you squidding me right now
reflin
reflin that's so mean
I'm done so well
reflin
you're so stinky
thank you for the
the tip are you serious
putters
you're bad
oh I need to do it again
oh no I don't
I think I'm doing
oh no okay maybe not hold on
what the
right
I can see
these lines I think that's what it is
there's like lines here
are you the next tallest
line oh no you're the tallest
line line line
nope that's too much of a gap
line
too much of a gap
uh huh
don't hurt him now don't hurt him now
mm-hmm oh yeah
okay
haven't used my brain that's okay
first thing in the morning
only forever sleep
that's okay
it's not
my favorite but I'll do it
for you
that's your favorite
okay mm-hmm uh huh
oh yeah oh my god
she may actually be enjoying this a little too much
most enthusiastic
uh VTuber about this game
because I didn't think I had the IQ for it
long
oh my god oh my god
I can't believe we're doing SPH on main
why are you not
staying in your assigned floor
right now over
over V1
that one
oh no not you
over one more
aww there's like a little shaving
some in a little pile
oh
get off the screen
mitten's worth
you're being so disruptive
you really are
she's getting her serotonin for the date
for real
I'll even order your favorite dish from Zanzibar
ooh we're playing a record
aww
what's wrong I don't know
what's wrong
why I scream like that
oh wait am I to find the one that doesn't have a
no they all have a scratch in it
bruh stop spinning
no legit stop spinning
alright so we can
is there one that doesn't have a cat scratch on it
oh
oh what did I not do
okay I should get some sleep
please rest well those who need to sleep
don't worry I've always been chilling
and the endurance streams come back
later in the week
and then we're going straight back into it
okay so please don't worry
aww this one's about our home
our home together we flin
see ya
yah
try to figure out how you're supposed to do it any other way
but
use boom boom right
oh my god we learned how
to do our own
home
pickle in
even though it's super dangerous
I'd probably kill a little bit
juice levels
oh there's three different ways you can do that
probably the height and then
the number of stuff in the jar
yeah
spoon
the lorry
let's do it by measuring
oh this is so cute
what the heck
no
does it not spin
are we being pranked
is there like a secret gap that is not
insertable
oh
I see it now
sorry
I was like
don't work in here
okay we got bowls
oh they need to like match
sorry
okay
love it
ta-da
sorry this game's so cute
oh my god I'm giving it a 10 out of 10
what the heck I thought I was going to be like
stress on this entire stream
oh we're in a space wreck
um
not beating the smoke detector
allegation
my streamer cannot be this silly
um okay this
looks a bit
one shade
to another
and then it gets more pure
or maybe it's the
oh
is that one way
ah okay the other way will be like
the hill of the space I think
whoever controls the space
controls the universe
egg
wah
I can see it ding ding ding ding ding ding
yeah I saw it right
wait I love this thing
I love this thing
oh I hate the scratch it's like oh no
oh these are bread holders
these are in Australia
are they Australian
is that thing
oh am I connecting them together
okay hold on
okay not you
okay can't be you
okay
don't hurt him now
nope
okay maybe hurt him a little
nope we're getting there
hold on let me
should really be using my eyes for this
to be honest instead of just spamming it down
but you know what sometimes
okay can't work there
who is supposed to fit over there
hold on hold on
like I don't know it looks like
you should fit but I guess not
oh oh
oh
can't even be that way
okay
can he move all this over
no can't be that one
okay hold on hold on
wait
nothing
oh I see I see I see
but I thought that I was gonna say that
I need to like move this over
okay
that's not it
oh crumbs
get out of here
goodbye
we'll worry about the bits later
sweep them on the floor was that cheap
and that's just some luck
honestly
they're holding hands
there's two tags
get off
we're littering
we've become the very thing we swore to destroy
get rid of them
how many
what a week
I'm watching on your lunch break
enjoy your lunch make sure you chew your food
don't talk
speak in a lunch
what
okay
can you
maybe thickness
we do a little girth analysis
around these parts
oh no
okay hold on what
are we doing groups
are we segregating fucking pasta
what's going on
uh
what
right thick
twisty twisty twist
what we doing like thickness
no
I got no clue
put pasta in the box
length perhaps
uh
hold on let me use my eyes
maybe
oh this one's not easy
what
how curly is it
so curly
oh
separate it from the twist
what so paying you straight
you're kinda just about to get a bit
curvy
and then all the way over here
twisty twisty twisty
big twist
oh
we did it
mitten's worth you're really starting to
mess us up
that was tricky okay hold on a minute
VV may have been on
or something
did the fishy
please make the thing again
I wasn't paying attention
I'm cheating
I'm wholeheartedly cheating
okay
I don't know what I was supposed to do with that one
what am I looking at
three houses, two birds
those are different birds
I had no idea
level
water level, nope water level can't be
what was
I'm cheating
I'm cheating I don't even know what the heck
I was supposed to do this one looks so random
the seagull one is completely throwing me off
like this one
two birds
curious
they all have seagulls on them
dinner
yeah British
you always have
mitten's worth
you're causing a comeuppance
no
mitten's worth still bet
I'm going to see even for
tating 250 items
mitten's worth
you're ruining the vibes
the vibes
a conanino
please don't ever make that noise again
right toast always goes in the top right corner
I don't care what anyone says
what
I thought you weren't supposed to play with your food
egg on toast
oh this one's got me stoned
what
huh
so
this is some
yeah what that's what good
nevermind
uh
wait a rotate it
okay
oh
oh wait okay
oh my god
don't hurt him now
let him get up let him get up
okay
oh my god yes
yes
oh that was a good one
sorry it was
yeah it was frustrating but it was a good one
oh
put her food
three three green
three oh well
oh my god
I'm so smart
I did it
I couldn't verbalize anything
I was doing it right there
or else I wouldn't have been able to do it
so I'm sorry that was just me going
honestly if the make didn't have a filler
this is what you'd hear
oh wait hold on let me meet the game
just so you can really get the full effect
because that's how I think
I can't verbalize it or it's not gonna work
yeah
do it in terms of the buttons
this fucking cat now
sorry I think Gimli was trying
to break in there
she is trying to break in at my room
Gimli
oh is that
wait is that the in-game audio
oh it's the in-game audio
oh my god I'm screaming at my cat
and she's not even doing anything
okay it's the in-game audio
that weird noise you hear
let's push this
oh my god I thought I literally thought
the cat's name is Gimli
Gimli's got a bit of ginger on her
so I named her Gimli
and then when I pick, well
I've actually started to pick her up a little bit
which is something too bad
and I couldn't go that's my weird loud Gimli
they actually did really well
when my dad was visiting
both Gimli and Vigo
what the heck am I doing
sorry
hold on we need to cheese it
cheesing
looking for cheese
looking for cheese, looking for Bri
looking for Guto
what other name did she say
looking for Cheddar
yeah what is this one
looking for cheese
is it colors? the ones that are colored
go together
no it can't be
connect the river
connect
the river
connect the river
Connect the river.
The text help.
Welcome.
I think you have to make a big picture you see the river connecting the
greetings and wish you were here greetings yeah greetings I wish you were
here why don't you stay a while stay a while home
greetings from parental park adventure who's fucking put this game on what
I'm really struggling to see this one I can't see it wish you were here and
greetings links up for like nothing else is a massive fan work about shipping
Gimli and Legola lunch has been inhaled need the I'm like okay clouds on
cloud clouds okay okay don't hurt him now don't hurt him now okay so let's put
these over here okay okay all right okay okay okay okay okay we're getting
somewhere don't know where it is but wait for you carry me through a game
you can also skip in the menu when you're so close but it's so far away I can
I genuinely can't see it I cannot for the life of me see it I mean that coincides
with like the green but nothing is like good job
we may have to do a skit adventure and home connect on the river adventure and
home connect okay uh-huh okay I see it now mm-hmm I'm what I do with that
information
welcome why don't you stay a while green screens from the park wish you were
here because adventure awaits but then you go back home what does that mean
in the wrong place
The answer is in the long term
Where's Rick?
I thought you two come together
The answer is in the long term
How can it be?
How can it be? What's going on?
What's going on? Why? Why?
Home goes on the other side of steel
Yeah
Right, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay. We're getting there. We're getting there. We're getting there. We're getting there
Let's just move everything up a little bit. Okay, river
A little wider than a mile
I'm crossing you in style
some day
Oh
Wherever you go
What
Adventure awaits
Adventure waits is the first one on the left
Who picked this color scheme?
I don't see it
What like that?
What the fuck?
Is that what you want from me?
All the way left adventure waits
What's going on?
Like this
Oh
No
Shit one. No, no, no
Robert don't talk to me. That was absolutely awful. Right. Okay. Let's try again
Let's go again. I'm addicted to the serotonin
Right, what is this?
Oh
Okay
A little bit of honeycomb
A little bit of monocled
A little bit of it is all I need
What the fuck is this?
Oh no, hold on a minute
Vivi might have actually had some I don't know do hey do hey do hey do hey
Do hey do hey
Hey do hey
Or is this supposed to be a secret and it's not really that hate so it doesn't get to go there
Yeah
Okay, mm-hmm
Okay, mm-hmm. Yeah, okay. I'm starting to understand why people hate this game. Okay. What do you want from me?
Is this the content? What the fuck?
Who or what are you spitting at the puzzle?
What?
What do you want from me?
You want to kiss me?
Make it more
I don't I don't know you
I don't know you want you want to be honest
What do you want?
Just move it a little to the left. You know what?
You know what? You know what? You're the first to get our word in the train. Sorry. I really shouldn't make
And yet I do what happens. What happens? I don't know
What are you? What are you saying?
Right, hold on. Let's go
Let's do wit
Again, the milk is the wittiest boy
Right, you're skinny melinky long legs. So don't
Right, let's do witt
Um
I'm stumped. I don't know what it is. Uh, something about the colors
Okay, let's okay
Something about the colors
Colors, uh, love them. I'm not colorblind. Lucky me. Uh, yellow
Oh
Something about the colors
Um
Oh
What what are you asking for
I've no go clue colors
You know last time magic segregation was like way back in the fucking past. What the fuck are we doing sort by colors for?
What the fuck? I can't figure it out
Purple right, there's purple here a purple there. Then that's the balsamic fucking piece of shit
Right, so now what?
Align the labels
What they're supposed to fucking kiss
Where how is that supposed to
I
What what even is this laying the labels on my back
What it's all supposed to like touch or something
Olive oil next to the milk
So
Whatever vv said about this game she was right
What
I can see something forming here
I don't think we should all the luck
I don't even have a brain cell to talk and try and figure this out at the same time. Are we skipped you doodling?
I think you're overthinking it. Well, how do I open up the menu?
Tubbs and mayonnaise to milk to balsamic
There's a fucking line there's a hidden line
Right tub to mayonnaise to milk
Tub
To mayonnaise to milk something I already forgot
Ah
It's milk to balsamic to thingy to the medium the milk to the stomach
I still not afraid again
So
Space them
Oh
Yeah, that's getting a bit too much
That's getting a bit too much hold on a minute. VV was right. Hashtag VV was right. I'm not even being funny
Oh
Are you trying to soften me up after that one?
pooders
Any cheesers it's been funny, but I've got a shower. Oh, yeah, the puzzle really got you good
Oh, okay, right I can tell the story um
Okay, he has an idea. He wants to spill the drink. Okay. He drops the bath and the drink and plant
Wait, we're just taking photos of our cat destroying stuff. We're like we're just letting it happen. Um
Oh, no, it's going downhill. I thought I was doing so well, but my logic isn't
Uh
The reason the earth is not flat is this cat so didn't knock everything off switch the first
switch the first
second
And throw the round
You guys watch me do it the wrong way
I
Wait if I don't every combination but the correct one
You guys have to look at the drink first and then he gets an idea to knock things over
Okay. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. He looks at the drink and then he gets a bright idea to knock shit over
And then he knocks stuff over
First he sees the glass and then the lamp
Okay, he sees it and then he gets a bright idea to start knocking stuff over
Okay, maybe another color puzzle
Nettie gray, how many chapters are there?
We're actually kind of get I mean we may actually do this. Hold on a minute. I have a little bit fee
I spoke far too soon and I'm sorry
Oh, I see something
Okay, I see something I see something I see something here
And this
There's five chapters I have a little bit of faith sees the next puzzle
Right these two fit
Okay, these three fit and the glove fits the fingerprints on that one. So
Okay, okay, okay
Okay, it doesn't work. Oh wait, those two work together
The bucket seems like it has to go there
Yeah
No, you can but you bump into him
All right, everything bumps into the bucket so the bucket has to go at the end
That is my only logical conclusion the bucket has to go there. Okay, right then we'll figure out what happens over here
Oh
Wait, what does it look right?
Everything looks correct other than this one go in the bucket go in the bucket
Go in the bucket
I'm cleaning them make them shine
This looks correct I gone crazy
This oh the sponge goes in the square space
Sponges, why are we no longer participating in the laws of physics all of a sudden
Why is physics just optional now in the game right? I'll need to keep that in mind
I
Physics is no optional got a G's right big batteries
I am speed
You don't belong here
You might belong here though. Yeah, that looks correct correct in Mundo
Nope, you can't all fit in there you're too big
Okay, okay, okay
That looks
I mean them I'm gonna see
The yellow one on the place of the one
Thank you for rather violent
All you want to then
Okay, this one's cute I like it I like it I dig it I dig it angry sneeze
It was so loud my screen flickered. That's hilarious
What's wrong? Oh, that's right
That is different therefore it's wrong
Okay, there we go. Oh, it's a good one. Okay. I like that one. I like that one. Let him get up
Okay, the game might have redeemed itself slightly scream again, please. That was a sneeze
You've got coins. So this is a 50-pence coin
Okay
Go from a circle
Into a lesser circle over time
A circle how many sides one two three four five six
Seven eight nine ten one two three four. Oh you
Wait one two three four five six seven
One two three four five six one two three four five six nine
Ten
I'm sorry. I'm special needs. Hold on a minute. What I know what I'm trying to do but it's not coming out
So
Well, I just did more circling. Oh, they start
Why would you start
Why did you start
I
Mean
I'll take it. She's what that was an accidental discovery
Let's try that that was the
Maybe it's better to do the more obtuse items first
Is that even fit
That's what she said
Get it get it because
No, do the more obscure items you look obscure
Anything that looks mainly different than the usual getting out
What even is oh it's a tea infuser
You put your dry tea in it one chopstick
Sorry, there's a really good vein and the guy's like I'll have one
Of your ass or
No, no, no, no, no, you're not left to be
Being out here. What? Oh, it's one of those that makes sense
My god, I you knew it. Oh, you know it. You know it
Uh
Wait, is there only like one no, I can't hear it
Okay, the spoon has to be this one because of this little arch way thing going on I refuse to believe they didn't
We can oh wait, do the wee ones go together? Oh the wee spoons go there
Well, all done next round, uh, what
Anything like fine
No, this is correct
If I just shake it the game will surely accept it. Can you stack the red spoons again? They're stacked in a weird order
Sorry, sorry
Right just type in
Rebecca's
Take away, okay
And you'll understand you'll understand why I go out there
Because if you've got my accent, would you?
Wait until you open up
Today, we're going to pack this customer's order
They ordered a bit at Becca's munchie belongs. Sorry. The mixer doesn't fit
Uh-huh
Well, that doesn't go anywhere else either
Oh, we're opposite Greek and we don't have a paddle. It's the tea infuser
Oh
That was very specific. Um, I mean
It's all right. I'll get I get it. I get it. I could have got the hint because the things
I'm to go off of pure babes alone
Oh
I mean if the game helps me and points them the right way then sure, but uh
No
What
Okay
Yes
No, yes
I want to put it up
I don't know what's gotten into me today
It's clearly not
Stop stop talking do you understand? Okay
Oh, okay
Okay
I think we're doing it
Oh
Okay, what is this though packing peanuts
Strawberries and a mid-today we first prepare for the most intense ink extraction
No, I'm too depressed to express for right now, but uh, oh this looks like a nightmare
After I have a few days to recover
Please don't be surprised if I start using my alternative to wear a heck of a lot more
Oh, wait, is this a hint that the candles go here?
No
I'm a bit nervous on this one after
Right remove everything
Let's just close the doors not our problem
It must I hope it was
Okay, we're a bit of a rough start bit of a rough
Okay, this can't go sideways so the only place it literally can fit
Had a lot
I'm not satisfied
Oh
This is a tricky one
Oh, it's obvious
Dave
Oh, I need like
Oh, this one's a scary one
Hey, okay, that I'm satisfied with I'm satisfied with that. Okay. Let's get that right. I've got a knife
Got a knife
Maybe
It doesn't seem to go up and down so it has to be so good. So I'm gonna I'm gonna go to PR
I'm very unconfident
Sizzlers. Yep. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Let me get up
Ah
Usb it can go either way. It was oh no, can I go up and down?
What was that? No, I saw that I saw that you were trying to turn at something. What were you turning at be honest? Oh
Okay usb you fit there
This is a very specific strony. What do you have there a knife? No
All right, I'm gonna be honest with you
But there's only one two three four crayons
Is it possible that
I mean he fits when I go there. Where were the candles go?
Well, something please think of the candles the candles don't have a home if you steal them
I might have to go up here
Although they don't look very organized up here
And there's literally nowhere else for them to go so like
I don't have much faith in this one to be honest
Why are you going sideways?
I'm gonna put that one there for now, but I feel like that's a red herring, but it's okay. What do you?
I don't even want to know what that's useful
From tall it you have some more candles or more
But I don't what's
Maybe it is the section I mean
Maybe
They all look like the same height
Candles go top left
Oh my god, you're so right
You're actually so right
Four paper clubs
Buttons a whistle
One more
Right, okay, the candles I'm satisfied with I can see I've got two buttons
I've got three tax
One ear cleaner just randomly I'm gonna go that's what you use more for
I'm gonna do a short bit behind
Oh my god
You guys go in here
You
Can go up here and what all the guy oh, I guess like one two three. Oh
Oh my god
I did it
Oh my god, I had no faith in that one. Thank you for the candle hen. I wouldn't have got that
I'm not even gonna pretend. I wouldn't have got that
one singular
Now try to imagine what purpose this kit has truly
We need to drip the pink floors
Okay, I like that one
You can't do it mommy. What are you supposed? Yeah, you I call that I call that you're supposed to be cheering me on
We all saw what you taped. We know what you taped last summer
We yeah, yeah, yeah, we saw what you take
I clocked I clocked you like
What are you can't do well
I
Mean
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, okay close nice and easy. Okay like no one also
Hey, everyone was like in the scene of bits of the games a noider so far
We go the fridge one. I don't agree with
Oh my god
Refleens we need to find the key to your cage. Stop stop. That's not funny
One two prying one frame one frame
That looks like the Elden Ring
Game or brain rot setting and I'm so sorry. We can't leave our cage mercy one less. Oh, no, no, not that kind of cage
We're not sniffing it's more
Preferable we lock you up in an hour. Oh, imagine locking me up just to send me a bed, right? Let's do
Len
Okay
Lent first
Oh, I've just noticed you know what I've just noticed as this doesn't work
There's like numbers of rings in here like two rings
five holes three
Um
Oh, no, I accepted the length. Okay. I accept it. Okay. I was gonna say yeah, definitely something with the holes three one four six two
Something something, you know
I think that'll be the alternative
Okay
Why is there a golden tooth? Why would you keep that?
Okay, we've got an acorn
We've got a doo-dah I need pee actually. Oh my god. I'm allowed to pee on streams again
Right, this is clearly too big for that section so we can only go in this section
I'm gonna remove these because I'm not sure how much I believe them
Uh
I don't know
Really
Ha always so illegal
Would you see what I mean what my pee oh the tooth the golden tooth sorry I was like, yeah throw it in the toilet right now
Jack has the thank you for the extended membership world domination
Thor it invest in pattern recognition security real true
Oh the nails then they are hold on do you go there?
Oh, no, they got a little bashed up in transit. It's okay. Oh, no that one's even more bent. Holy moly moly
There's nothing to be embarrassed about if you're a little bit
perfectly natural
What an earth goes in these wee slots. What did you call me? Um
Maybe up here for you guys
Got a lot of them
I love the bendy one
I
Strongly defeated by a singular capture AI generated cut first broad Twitter every time I send a DM to someone Twitter's like
Prove you're not a bot and I'm very clearly just doing bot training like very fucking clearly doing bot training. Okay that
Okay, okay, okay
Um, and I'm like broad give it a rest. I'm literally just trying to be in folk
Okay
Mm-hmm
Okay, no
Maybe maybe okay
Look at my little baby my baby not in there
Where the I'm just gonna shove the acorn there for now because I have no
Okay, let's do this. Let's do this. Okay. Okay. Let me get up here. Whoo
Yeah
Yeah, okay. All right. All right. All right. All right. All right, right. What do you do? You go here and
Oh, I get it. I get it. I get it. I get it. I get it. Oh, look at
I serve this is one
Oh, is this a cabinet
For a piece
Okay, everything out everything out right now
Oh, my god, it's my oh, this is why recording is more with I use like a Japanese ear cleaning brush
It makes the best
I guess
Okay, that is a moveable
Very big
These are all very big I am
I
Go ahead. I'm gonna let the pee
That's a lot of lotion
No, I see it. I see one. Yes
Okay, that looks correct to me. I don't know about you. That looks
Lighting
Would a normal q-tip do the job? No, the Japanese ear. Oh, sorry. The Japanese ear cleaning tool sounds a lot different from
From a q-tip
Oh my god, you'd be a ring on a shelf. I don't know
Is that an upside down floss thing?
Toothbrush yes, and then toothpaste
That was an empty toothbrush go in the bin can't be that empty can you
Hmm
I'm a bit perplexed. No
Oh and a jar
No, and the lid take the lid off. Yes
I knew it was to go in here
No, I need the foam. Thank you
Okay, all the ear cleaners are wasted lid back on
Oh
I'm never fighting with this stuff
Um
I'm fighting I don't know if I'm winning but I'm fighting
Oh
Okay
Right uh-huh, uh-huh
Oh
Okay pilot time I'm going to get a cola as well. So I'll just be a moment time for a pee. Oh my god. Oh my god
I'm just reading
Wow, I'm a bit slow today. That's not gonna stop me. I might be a wee bit slow, but just give me a second
You want to pee with me peeler
Oh
Are you squidding me right now?
I
Just did a princess pee. I sent it to me. Oh, no, don't give me don't don't don't do that
Stop I forgot you guys did that when I go for the toilet need strongly to sort my life next chat. Oh
That's stop right
Are you squidding me right now?
Jesus
Dory and doomsday done. I poor rey kuma sleepy phoenix reluctantly saying reefling cuttles scott thunder
Cade on
and boy
Need strongly to sort my life next
um
What if I told you?
That your life doesn't actually have to amount to anything and the pressures you put on yourself are due to the
Finish it due to the what society we live in what the
It's over
It's over. Oh, how it's so over
Due to the I'm waiting for one person to say it surely someone's gonna say the the c word
Oh
My gosh, what even is this one?
Due to the high table the capitalistic society
Yes, you do not actually have to be productive you have been taught this because
You are to be a made a product of the machine to explore
What's that a beacher
A beacher for his radicalizing news more news. It's like
We are oh, no, this is a nightmare
Is there obvious ones? I don't want to start putting stuff up until there's obvious
Feed the machine don't bite the heck I never said to hold 30% back for the tax man for nothing
And each of her radicalizes you against the high table a smart I am so excited
So I'm a bit to burp that
Swallowed the air wrong. I am so excited to record on my meme ASMR. I'm going to do the pregnancy ASMR first because that's hilarious
Rob, how are you supposed to guess?
You just have to see what fits
I'm made to be a product of mommy's honey tea. Okay, that's the only kind of productive a low
Oh
Fucking call it what the fuck is this man doing?
No, I can't be right
A
tackle
They um have absolutely zero faith
Where am I even supposed to fit this wait, what do you get called? Oh that wait
Up here
Okay, that looks correct. I'll take that so that can't be correct
Oh, no, it can't be correct
Oh, this is not going to be an easy one I'm just
Right now that can't be right. Maybe a baby one. Okay. Okay
Okay, okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. All right. All right. All right. All right
When I realize how everything is set up all I'm saying was going to be a minimum
Do you get paid minimum wage make sure you put minimum effort in
Okay, I'm gonna be honest. I think I need to look up a cheesy noodle for this one. This is insane
This is just a circle. So there it is for the circle. It's just a bit tape. I'm not supposed to do with that
I think the axe goes where the thought is I'm listening. I'm listening the axe
Is that what you meant? No
No, it can't be
You should give the energy you get never mind. Yeah, of course Johnny would be telling us the threat
I can't believe you guys aren't going to twerk for me at the convention. Don't be so red
Oh that kind of compliments
Right
I might need Kamala to look at the hints for this one. So looks great. Try moving
Try moving lever
Level next saw
Mm-hmm
Everyone close your eyes and three two one. Okay, just close your eyes for no
No
Close your eyes
Thank you for closing your eyes for no reason at all
Okay
What was it I've already forgotten shit don't
Right screwdrivers on this. Okay. That's what has
Right. Thank you for closing your eyes. Okay. You may open them again. Sorry. I just have to do a quick costume change
Um
Fuck is a screwdriver. Oh, it is. Okay. Okay. No
Can't be that one
What did you hear my stomach all of them in being sewn I can't be right
I
Don't know what happened to my eyes. So you just closed on the room and perceived no
My work put pushed me around a lot these promotions that uh
It was worth in the end because now my job is watching tv and drinking coffee
Oh real true. Love it. I love when this when you work the system. Give me stories where you work the system, please
I think I told you guys that when I worked in a care home, they used me for embezzlement
of
wages
Because when I left they gave me like an extra 700 quid and I was like I had to phone off and I was like
Something's not right here. Smile and they were like, uh, yes. Just take it and I'm like, okay
He's by me arguing
Up here
Oh you go awful awful try again
Are you guys gonna have to close your eyes again? Sorry, I just don't want you seeing things that you're not ready to see
When you get older, you know
What how is that supposed to get that sorry
How
Who what we were in my house, please tell me there's not one person in this world that actually done the same naturally because that's
Wait, I've already forgotten the rest
Already forgotten
You got hypnotized to have free will
The weird pink thing goes under the screw that
I think it's about lining up the pegs
And the sheets
Yeah, like the difficulty. I mean normally I do play legendary
Real truth. So we're not telling peppers. I was
I like the story in
Heck would go here
No
Bizarre
Bizarre and ain't jojo's
What is culture is culture is mommy needs a hint. Sorry. This was far too difficult for me
Mechanical thing mechanical thing mechanical thing circle spatula
Mechanical mechanical mechanical circle
Spatula
How did I cheat and still get this wrong
I
I'm looking with my eyeballs. How did I cheat and still get it wrong? What's what's not right?
Wait
Hold on
Hammer and wrench thingy in the bober hammer and wrench hammer and wrench. Okay, that's correct
Caliper scissors done that done that spatula little drop thing
Hmm hammer spatula
Screwdriver is miscellane
I
Huh
The tape stopped us from getting that bro, that was not I don't know how that is even plausible
Oh
Look at me. I'm a 1950s housewife. Okay. Now what?
Oh, there's like different ways. Maybe we should try a few the different ones
Uh
I don't know if you hear my cola camera. I just think let's take everything out because these clearly aren't giving me a hint
one air
There's a lot of round shaped things
The shoes as well, I feel like shoes
Does it matter if you know? I feel a lot of round things with a ball
Ball ball
A shuttlecock is technically sports. Yes, it's called a shuttlecock
Grow up
And then do a meme where you look old like put on a meme old filler
Shawnee makes us lunch when we go to work and construct in the reef and farm
Bro, we're gonna be more efficient than the Amish
Okay, another shoe
A ball
Plant pot. Oh gardening gardening gardening
I see it. I see it. Okay, and then technology
Okay, technology. What the
ball
Gardening gardening technology technology technology. Oh gardening technology
Gardening gardening technology
uh
Technology
Wow, I didn't even know what it was
How would the Amish react to seeing a beach over for the first time?
Critical mass heart attack
I'll shut your cock. Whoa. Hold on a minute. Oh
Okay, follow the arrows arrow goes along
Uh, don't do it to me like this are you serious?
No, not a certain puzzle. I can see the arrows is like go here then go there and then I need to put this one here
And then that one there. Oh my god, it's like an actual
I'll just never get at these
I
Can't do these kind of puzzles
No, hold on. We're gonna brute force this right. I need this one here next. Okay, that's fine. I can do that
What I need it like
Wait, I'm gonna do it
Whoa
Am I being trolled
I'm genuinely being trolled
Wait, but no, I can't put it anywhere
I can
I
Mean
I can just start violently shuffling that like again, I can't do what I want to do what
I
Bulls this one up
You absolute arseholes
You are schools, you knew they knew what they did
Arseholes
Right, where's the box I even need this one? I think what are right?
I need that purple one
Oh, yeah, you know that one you said you just needed
Uh, maybe use your brain for like five seconds. She relaxes
That's been sold me so badly right
I move this one away now
I'm not wrong. No, I can't have
Oh
Okay
Yeah, no wait, hold on purple purple to white
Uh-huh, okay, uh-huh
Let nope let me go let me go
Okay, then wait and balloons wait has to go here. Okay
Uh-huh, sorry the tape doesn't align
Well, it goes pink up here, but I need white to go there
No, it's too tall
This is absolutely awful
Like I know what it wants me to do but
I
Unless I can just a really quick hail Mary
Oh
Here
So I want it
And maybe
It might be it might be
Okay
Okay, am I doing it? I might be
Oh
No, I have to move it all over by one
Can I just control all the
I had to move it over by one
Hold on
Maybe it's not as bad right hold on. Let me get up
Let me get
Hmm I've already unlocked again purple purple into white
Oh, I'm gonna fart bro
Purple into white
Oh
Baby what I need that I need access to that one
Okay, okay, hold on hold on don't give up yet don't give up yet
Right, I need this later. Oh shit. No, right walk goes under
Oh
Um
I need that one to literally go along one
You're blocking it to go along one. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay
Oh
Don't
Okay
Yeah, no, they're literally like, yeah, we know you spent an ungodly amount of
I'm not even doing the second thing. What the heck that was
Awful, sorry. I had my mouth covered like I had my hand over my mouth. So I'm so sorry if my tracking was like dead
Oh, they've got wee bonies
Okay, let's get you nice and polished
That polish the pedals as well. Oh wait, I need to rotate it, don't I?
Oh
No, they get depressed when the catcher's open
It's a big dramatic for a game like this
Chapter four in our nature. We may actually do it
We may actually do it real
We may be two hours in but we may actually do it
There's only a little bit
Oh, I really fixed it everything the cats demolished. Oh, I like that
Oh, I like this
Oh
I get his near the kitty made my flipper look real true. Can't use the final ball
We clean up the cough. No, we don't see okay
Oh, we're cleaning up after the kitty. I'm not even mad. Let's pick up for the mug. Oh, no, let's fix the rug
Are you squiddin me right now? There's more Brian
The strontis trainer well done strontis such a good girl from clean the puzzle bot. No. No, I'm gonna sign this up
Oh, there's more
Must be under the newspaper
Oh, thank you for the tips strontis trainer really have to see it like that
Let's get rid of that. Let's get rid of the ball frame
Oh
The leaves are stopping me from cleaning the plop run
Oh, I love this level
I want to clean up after the poody as long as the poody cat has fun and enrichment
Oh, give me the rug back give it back
No, stop it. You're putting more dirt on the floor kitty
Kitty I'm trying to know how to get right
Oh, I missed I missed. Oh, that was lucky. You almost got that. Take that. I thought thank you. Ah, give it back. Give it back kitty
Ah
No, he keeps stealing it. I'm like literally doing it so fast. Sorry. Okay, there we go. We got it. We got it. We got it
My kitty stealing my ring
Wow, that was a cute one. I like this puzzle and like this chapter
Oh
Oh, we're preening so the reason
I fucking got tame challenge what the fuck
Oh, god, what the right? That's definitely not doing right. Hold on. Why am I not doing it right?
Mm-hmm
Oh
One
No, what?
Right. It can't be that
Rotate the fuck out of this plank. That's not the mission objective
Go for symmetry
So
Symmetry
I
Would not have gotten that ever
I would not have gone that ever if he didn't say that I would not have figured that out that was far too difficult
Oh, it's um, okay deep red
Changing hues thank goodness. I'm not colorblind, huh?
Yeah, okay. Okay. I saw it. I saw it. I've done something's off for the queue. Perfect. It's the
This is very bright on me eyeballs. Oh, they're kissing
Yes, I'm off the screen. Uh
Which one has the cat on it pick a jar any jar any jar at all
It's yours. I promise there's money and I'm not scamming pick a jar any jar refling any
Uh
Oh, I see it. I see it. I saw it see it see it sword
Yeah, I see with the leaves even here
The right jar
You see emmy's ginger when she's clearly blonde and what universe is she blonde?
I don't know if this is like a culture thing or something and what universe is any blonde genuinely
She's clearly a yin-yang
So I'm not really sure why it's even up for debacle
I was very surprised when she was like, I'm I'm ginger
Yes, emmy you literally have orange hair your ginger
She's definitely blonde. Oh wait, are you being serious or am I getting trolled?
Am I being trolled? I'm unironically doing a poll right now. I think this must be a culture clash
because
uh
What?
Oh, that's me. Hi. Um
Hold on start a poll
Oh, I just closed the tab. Well, nice try. Let's try that again. We should try another poll. Gee
Okay, add poll
What hair
Hair color do you think emmers is question mark?
She's
She's ginger
Orange and brackets for those of you who are dumb
Because you're a dumb dumb if you think she's literally blonde
she's
Blonde and brackets yellow
And what?
Right there we go start full
Okay, I'm literally doing a poll and chat right now
What hair color do you think emmy is she's ginger and brackets orange? She's blonde and brackets
Yellow in what world is she actually blonde? Please be so for real right now. Are you mental?
I think she's a ginger blonde. No, you cannot be ginger blonde. You're either a ginger or you're a blonde
She's blonde at the top and it transitions to gingerish near the bottom. I've shown you her concepts are she's a yin or
Literally pumpkin hair. She's pumpkin themed voodoo doll themed
She's a yin or
I hope the last option is now do a poll for as there is hair color. Oh, you guys are gonna be split on that one
See you elite. I don't 35% of you think she's blonde. I used to be honest. Are you strong? Do you actually think she's blonde?
Thank you for the tip tiny spainy. How is she blonde? She's orange. She's a pumpkin. Her hair is themed after pumpkins
orange
Oh
Right now to do the real one. Okay. The veal or hair colors are the real a little bit bro, right? Let's do a zero
Azura's
hair color is
Green
blue
Okay, there we go
All right, those never pull up for Azura's hair color
I
Your choice is is it green?
Are you
I'm not even teal. Are you squidding me right now?
I don't have a said blonde liar
absolutely
Azura is literally a blue green mix. It's called teal. That's what I said. She's teal
It's awkward marine, which is a shade of green. No, don't say such things. It's seafoam green, which is green
No, don't say such things
Do you have long and right? I'll tell you what we're gonna look at. Azura's a seafoam
Mostly blue with hints of green teal would be mostly green with hints of blue
Oh
Are you squidding me right now?
We're being debated unironically
Pull up the color chart. You know what maybe her
Her concept art was a bit more accurate. Thank you tiny spanish. Thank you. Okay. Don't are you squidding me right?
Maybe it's a strawberry blonde. What universe? Hold on. I'm actually right strawberry blonde
Let's look it up and ask
That's orange
That's all I will literally show you the first picture that shows up
I'm getting heated. I'm actually getting heated
That's
orange
And what universe?
Where the fuck is the picture show me
Okay
Okay, this is what comes up
This claw is what comes up when you take strawberry blonde
It's orange. I'm sorry. It's orange. It's ginger
Oh my god
I'm getting trolled so hard. This is ginger. I type in strawberry blonde. Please your blood pressure. That's ginger. Thank you
And now you're saying Azura's got green hair. I'm getting trolled so hard. Oh my god the first oh
It's ginger. She's she's a yinya
Okay, right. Let's unbreak
The book is a logic puzzle on this yin. Like that?
What do you mean she's no ginger? I need her
I birthed her from my lungs. I'm convinced Johnny. She emmys 100 ginger
She's 100 ginger from the start
Her concept art. She's a pumpkin. She's based after a pumpkin and a
voodoo stuff
I were tame as she's still going down straight. I'm still going
I'm mlg at this game
Are you squidding me right now? Ah anonymous you need to visit a doctor. We are very worried for your eyes
Are you I'm not colorblind. I will rob. I don't know. Um, it must be a culture clash thing. That's just straight up ginger
Like what do you think a ginger person looks like then and then don't say eric from freaking south part
What is this I have no idea what i'm doing right now. I'm so sorry
I
Don't even have a hint of like where I can put anything
Speaking of so far crap
I
Just make them pairs. I mean I can do that easily
We'll crab legs are together little horns are together
With an iron horn
What? Oh, what was that?
Are you giving me a hint to where the location
You see she'll mirror it. Yeah
Are you squiddling me right now?
Don't worry trust chak chak knows best and will always help and never lie to you believe us
Yeah
Thank you anonymous
I do trust and believe in you but something
I find it hard to believe that I
Oh
Did he kiss
Though those two kiss why aren't you
Kiss right now
Kissing they are kissing those kiss really low
Nothing can touch
I
Put them over here
Oh
Is it gonna float in that's loaded in
I
Want to try and find a slaw
I'm trying to find it
Verical mirror image
You're probably making symmetry. Yeah, but like nothing's like being like I yes, I register in the spot
Try to find this
Have you ever done an IQ that yeah, it's gonna be a don't it's our reward though
It's gonna be a very low result. That's all I can tell you
Oh
No, this oh
It's like half getting dragged half not right close your eyes. I'm sorry. I need to like I don't actually know where it wants
Fucking throw on the
Oh
No pumpkin space not no
No, no
Mommy's cooking right now this
Is that
Benny
Benny no
What what everything is doing a little down to down
No
Oh
The cat literally try to give me a hint
Hydration check replaying
How long will your donut on me?
Um, I'm doing a 48 hour one
Azura has to do a 12 hour one. Um just for living situation, but I think she'll be able to do that after it, which I'm very excited
Right, okay. Um
Actually, I need to write Azura's donut phone stuff out because she did it with a bleeding heart
So I need to come in and be like, okay now do this
48 hours, yes, uh
I think mercy will be moved out by the time her donut phone comes around
So she can do 48 hours as just as there is cases about you
No, I wanted to make a bulb
Is this symmetry again
I
Is oh my god, hold on. I need to like open my eyes really wait to do this
Hold on hold on. Sorry. I probably look really weird right now. I need I can't compare if my eyes aren't like wide open
Hold on
You
Uh-huh. Oh you
Do
Are you squidding me right now?
Oh, jackson's job. Hey stony. Thanks for feeling her. Oh, my nice of you. You're welcome. I'm glad you can enjoy the girls
It's only broken on stream. She's still reading
I'm like the chat disconnect. I hope no
Okay, right hold on. I need to do it again
I can't I don't want to say I can't see it yet, but I can't see it yet
Is it obvious and maybe
Oh you you're different
Okay, we did it. We did it. We did it. We did it. I got it. I got it. I did it
That was a little harder than I thought. I had to like
I don't know if you can see how well my eyes track. Uh, but that was like I had to go for it
Okay rocks
Man women love rocks
Gugli eyes
Gugli gugli eyes sweeties
Oh
Oh, I like this one
I like it very much. It's that's a good one. Very nice. Good one. Good one. I like that one
Oh, these are lotus seeds
Oh, they're all seeds. Oh, I love this one. Oh, those are the windfall seeds
What are you
I make them kiss
Oh, no, is it symmetry again? Be honest. I think it may be
Oh, it's symmetry again. All right
All right. All right. All right. I know she's about to ask this is her seed spread
Mommy puzzle moment puzzle. She disconnected from it. Is chat disconnected?
Will you and the girls ever use scripts posted to read it? No, we need the legal copyright
Of it. So we can't use that kind of stuff unless like someone came to us and we're like, hey
I give you all rights to this
Oh
But no, we cannot do that for copyright reasons
Wow, I love this one. It's so pretty just like you're reefing pretty little puzzles
What are you? I don't even know what seed you are. That's fantastic
I
Poppy this is a poppy seed. This is where you get opium from
Yes, I'm telling the truth
if you didn't know
Okay, and where when our derivatives of a plant
Um for the poppies you have to slash them before they bloom and then they'll secrete the opium
It's rather fascinating. Honestly, that's why like
Meth is because it's like lab made it's so dangerous and much more addicting because like literally it was produced to be that way
So very scary stuff. That's why you should never smoke crack
Because it's man made and the effects are insane
Whereas at least if you did her um cooking or heroin, you know, it's from a plant. So
It's a little bit better
Because it's not as bad, but it's not necessarily that good as well. So don't get
Is
Well, these three are the same color and have stripes these
Oh, but that one's the same
You're the only thing we need. Ah, are you so sweet people?
Well, you ever have male members in veal or sadly not no, um
The reason veal work is
You know can work is because the team is female content careers behind the scene
um
And unfortunately like I can't advise on male creation because I
What the heck am I supposed to do
This one's a curious pale
Hmm
Maybe if it's got like black
Like
That's got pink pink pink
Green
Why am I trying to achieve I'm not really sure I'm trying though
Oh, this one's tricky
Competing as a meal. Give me that strontium baby
Solids in the corner
Oh
That's so good. Good catch reflin. That's such a good one. Oh, I like that one
I would never have thought of that. That was a good one
Mild case of severe strontia addiction
Stainless reflin
Oh dear, right. We need a corner piece if there is any
Dear
I really feel like there's much corner pieces at all. Well, maybe you
Think
Hmm
Oh wow, I'm struggling with this one, wait let me kick a little bit though.
I don't have any corner pieces, how can I be, oh, is it color-
I can't be color-coordinator, so I'm gonna puzzle together.
How can a puzzle be a puzzle if it isn't puzzle-together?
It's a myth.
No.
Let me try to quickly find the solution, I'm sorry!
That was like a corner piece.
Maybe?
Pink when you have in top right should be bottom right.
I knew that.
You're on about honestly, I'm so obviously-
I don't know, do you get embarrassed being wrong all the time, refund?
Let's try to do that.
Oh that looks right.
Oh yeah, ooh up a bit.
Well that looks correct.
Look they're kissing!
Hmm, doesn't seem too right on this bit, I'm not convinced.
Need to kiss another day because I don't think-
Okay that looks more like a okay, how?
Okay you, you kiss right now.
Okay, okay.
Uh-huh, uh-huh.
This is not look right to me at all, what the fuck, I see so hard.
Kicking? I don't know, am I kicking? I don't know what is the little green one
in between.
Very true, very true.
But I cannot do shapes at all.
Well no, these- right, so don't get rid of it just yet, but-
Bro, I can't do isometric shapes!
Oh, what? Nothing fits!
I don't look right.
Like that, no.
Right, okay, hold on.
It's just- okay, okay, okay.
Okay, okay, okay.
I'm here for uh-huh, maybe, possibly, possibly.
Uh-huh, uh-huh. Okay, okay, don't, don't, don't let up now.
Don't let up now, oh, oh, oh!
We did it! That was so good! It all came together!
Yeah, you can do it, replaying, see? That's proof why you gotta keep
persevering. It doesn't matter if you keep jamming it in over and over, you'll
eventually get the result you want.
Stronikals 2024, thank you.
Okay, let's see what we're dealing with here.
Hydration check! What do you mean by that? Hydration, hydration, hydration!
Are your, are your strontium copium levels going up?
Know that I can do longer streams again?
Oh, is this symmetry be honest?
Oh, actually, I just clicked off him. It is symmetry, right, okay.
Oh, are we free of restrictions? I thought we had a little more time.
Um, I'm still feeling depresi-wessy because my dad's gone.
Um, but I am going to focus on the work that I missed because there's a
lot of v-tubers that are waiting for me to edit the collabs that
they were very keen to agree to me with. So I've got a bit of a work ahead but
don't be surprised when there's a bit of an explosion of ASMR videos on my
YouTube channel or on Patreon as well.
Um.
It's symmetry. Kitty! No, you're doing it.
Symmetry's in a lot of pockets. Yeah, this seems to be the reason.
I hope you feel better soon. Yeah, it's trying to explode on Patreon, yeah.
No worries, take your time, yeah. Um, it's why I picked three shorter games, just...
Eh.
Oh wait.
Is that what I'm supposed to find?
I think so, I think I just suck on putting it in, please.
Oh, you zoom out.
Oh, there's snowflakes.
That's not right then.
Did you know something, something snowflakes aren't all equally created or
something? Ah, I found it.
Uh, well your gemmets put ASMR in their Patreon channels as well.
Yes, they already have audios of the variety up.
More?
Oh, more.
Okay, and then we just need the ends.
They're like little banisters. Okay, this one is a cute one, I like that one.
That one's a good one, good one.
Are you gonna make more hypno stuff? Uh, not on Patreon because it's a ban.
I'm not allowed to put it on Patreon, unfortunately.
Okay, the section, okay. And this one, that's such a good one.
I'm here for it, it's a sad one.
Mmm, but I'll put it up on Twitter, I have a four part series on Twitter.
Once I edit it, I need to edit it first. I've got a lot of editing I need to do
actually over the next few days, but I'll get there.
Um, you just need to let me... Oh, this is such a good one.
I approve very much of this one.
Oh, bing.
Bing, bing. Yeah, that's what I thought.
You better be bing bonging me.
Oh, no. Can we release the slides?
Oh, no.
Oh, what's that? One, two, three. One, two, three.
One, two, three, four. One, two, three, four.
Um, Outside one, uh, Opposite again.
Oh, there's our spoiler. We fed the spoilers.
So proud of you working hard for this one. Yeah, I'm glad.
You guys enjoy. Near Earth organizer, what a strange name for a
chapter.
What's this about Hypno? I like Hypno content, but it's banned
on Patreon, so I have to do it on Twitter.
Huh?
What, is it not to go there?
What's that? Huh?
Oh my god, we have to tame it.
It becomes a donut. It goes in the hole. It comes on up.
Oh, I'm not going to like this one.
Okay, go here.
Oh, it's because we're in a coffee shop.
It's making coffee sound. Oh my god, that's such a strange one.
Okay, right. Then we're going to bring it back.
We're going to catch it. Then we've got the apple.
And we're going to put the apple in the golf.
Okay, and then we're going to put it in the cup of tea.
Right.
Bitch!
Right, apple into the golf.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa. You just, you just hold your horses, sir.
We're going to beat the golf into the constellation which drops into a tea or something. I don't know.
Oh, do I need to pot it? Maybe I need to pot it.
Okay, become a donut. Pull back.
And then loads of gravel here.
No. No, what?
Right.
Oh, no.
Okay, okay, okay, got worms. So what happens if I make it go right, sir? Does anything happen?
No, it's wrong. Okay, that's fine. Now I know it's wrong.
Oh, I've just put that in.
Right, become a donut. Unbecome a donut.
Okay, now we've got an apple. Now go to the golf man.
Beautiful, stunning, gorgeous. Now we are going to turn these right side
for some ungodly known reason.
I don't know why, but we are.
Right, well.
Oh, God, this is awful.
What? Am I not to put it in the hole? Be honest.
Oh, you need to overshoot the hole?
Who's supposed to figure that out in their day off?
Honestly. Right, go in the hole.
Go and become a golf ball. And then
and then just fucking send it.
I did that anyway. You're such a stinky game.
Patreon isn't stingy on it.
It's actually our Mastercard Overlord.
That is the reason why you can't do a lot of stuff.
So always thank you.
I'm sorry, was that yes to then posting?
I do it. I don't really ask the girls to do it just because it's a lot of
extra effort, but I could do it.
What?
Uh, I...
If you late, save for work, I can maybe get
Amy to do that.
You spin me.
That wanted to stroke midnight or something?
Wait, really? What's wrong with the two?
Oh, they dictate the whole world.
Mastercard dictate everything.
They are literally our overlords. Like, I'm not even kidding.
That's not me, like, tinfoil hatin'. They literally call the shots on the internet.
That's why Patreon ban, like, step...
Mm-hmm.
And, like, hypnosis, because they said it's, like,
there's no consent with it when literally that's
actually the entire thing about hypnosis.
Yeah, so you have to...
What am I doing here? I don't know.
Is it in the shadow of that line or something?
Mm-hmm.
Oh, I was typing it over, so I can mention
the PMIC process. They control the money.
Yep, server controls the Mastercard, controls the universe.
What am I trying to achieve?
I don't know.
Um...
What is this?
Mommy, I have to ask, but why is the thumbnail...it's glitched. The thumbnail's correct for me on my
end. I'm not sure why.
Does it...replay? Hold...right, close your eyes.
A singular pale?
A singular pale was my frickin' hint.
Don't look.
It's not a wild dog.
Oh, well, excuse me.
Hmm.
I'll try the quick question. How likely will this be?
Oh, no.
Huh? Are the shadows wrong? Are these shadows telling
you what goes in front of them?
What?
The horse just doesn't care.
He's just off on me.
Maybe who comes after?
Okay.
That doesn't make sense, though.
Symmetry with a horse in the middle?
No, those six people.
Maybe Merritt, hate on the shadows?
That's a good suggestion.
Unfortunately, that's not our solution.
What? Size order?
I don't know.
Staircase thing?
Oh, I just realized I'm covering up half of the puzzle.
Does that not bother anyone?
I'll just be a big-headed ass down here about that.
I don't know what you're talking about.
Keep playing.
You can move the shadows.
No way would they do a silly thing like that.
The game got real hard to look at every puzzle.
I think you're original in the right track.
Oh, it's a constellation.
What's that?
I'm too low IQ to discover such.
What's that? I'm too low IQ to discover such.
What's that?
What's that thing?
I don't know, but it's a map.
It's not even the map.
What's that?
I don't know.
I don't think so.
that was me me that's all I'm saying that was not me
was all the game because what I'm not I mean it's just discovering it itself
really who's that Pokemon I didn't see the chat I it's just kind of doing it on
its own I mean I'm not complaining I'll take an easy one kind of sliding in a
place of it honestly this game I didn't think I was gonna like it as much but
this is definitely like a solo experience you just want to chill out and
not really think too hard other than that kitchen one which was a complete
nonsense that was a bit like I'm not being funny but you're taking the piss
okay but everything else not really in it oh god I have to organize a desktop you
guys would cry if you saw my best time oh
okay at least put this stuff in a jar okay he's going on the wall
post it notes yellow green red oh yellow
I needed that oh the key all like the keys are golden okay sorry gold parts
yeah sorry I just the the apple the apple thing goes that way the timer oh oh I
see it I see oh my god this is a good one good one good one put it behind nope
try again yep right yellow orange green yellow orange green okay art
supplies red blue red red blue and then that one I guess the long oh the
shorthand we're done I mean no he's fine over there for the notes there for
the world I mean I mean I'm getting close the clock mummy the clock mummy
oh it does let me move the other hand sorry I thought it wasn't yes okay sorry I
didn't realize it was letting me move the other hand I found that was a good one I
like that one good one what green I put it in a blue it became purple if I put it
in purple it'll become red if I put it in yellow it becomes green right actually hold
on if I want to save a color keep it in here okay yeah that works okay but what
yellow we need I've got blue okay
that's yellow I just keep putting it until it until I get a green okay there we go
green yellow red oh okay okay I go away okay now what well I've lost it
soft locked myself then I think I need we start that one oh where did it go hello don't
come back where did it go I think a lot of on our own close off had a let's reset
okay so you know okay we're blue we go red we got yellow already we've got all
green I can't remember how about green I need green please
no give me green the green one oh there we go okay no I get the white one and it's
okay that's all it has to do and then disappeared okay it's fine it's fine we
got it hydration so this is about your stop I'm so addicted but I can't play
anyone didn't my candle stick is bigger than oh you you you
oh what
What?
Burning thing.
That's a friend turned spell at me.
I need to...
Aww.
I need to turn this around.
So peculiar, truly.
Yay.
They're getting bigger.
Refling, stop getting your tentacles with it.
No, it's not the tent.
You're trying to put it with your tent.
Burn them all again.
Don't ever touch an open flame in your home, if I will.
They're straight to me.
I've got a bit more on you.
Oh, you were right, Refling.
Thank you.
What was the other variation?
There seems to be another variation, is that one?
There's another one.
Right.
Oh, we've got a glace ball.
There's another one.
It looks nice and neat and tidy.
Let me clean your room again, Refling.
Your punishment for making me do manual labor.
Manual labor.
I'm making lemonade.
Oh, sweet skull.
I don't seem to pick up that one.
There's one of them.
Oh, I like this.
Oh, I do.
I see you, little fella.
I see you.
Can you open up?
You better unlock right now.
Oh, we're going to have problems.
We're going to have fisty cuffs.
Please open.
Oh, the hoops.
Oh, how creative.
Nothing.
Oh, the bits look correct.
Let's go back to the manual.
It's all good to me.
It's really exciting, right?
Misalignment.
Misalignment on pixel 234.
Please correct or you will not proceed.
I repeat, you will not proceed.
Let's go back up here.
Yeah, now the bits are stuck.
Hmm.
I don't need to put it on.
I can fucking chop that fast.
What is this thing?
You did that.
Yeah, it seems to be a misalignment on something.
Hmm.
Can you?
Who or what is misaligned?
Misaligned.
I think we may have to skip this one
to stack the book specifically over the wall.
The books are all in a line here.
It like bounces it off because it wants to show you the reflection of the stuff.
Does that make sense?
It wants to show you the reflection
so it's trying to bounce it.
Who goes there?
Hmm.
That's a shame.
Sorry, I'm satisfied that we did that.
I don't know how to chop this lemon
but it seems like a half or another thing.
We may skip it, you do that.
I think we did it.
Yeah, I think we did it.
Maybe the mirror is supposed to go all the way there.
I'm clicking that shit as hard as I can.
I think you need to get the mirror on right away.
Can you do like a little drive by just so the game moves?
It looks right to me.
Oh.
Open it, put it right.
And then put it to the right
for the books and that'll show.
I think it's being a bit silly.
I think it's being a silly Billy.
Hmm.
Okay, I think we'll go next.
Is it let it be mean skip?
Why would they go let it be?
Skip a level?
Yeah, it's because you guys are pissed.
You didn't code it right.
I got an achievement for skipping that level.
Okay, we have...
Oh, these are those chirpy birds.
I see all the buttons on.
I love it already.
I love not having to think for myself.
So...
Surely there's nothing better.
Um, to make a love fire?
Okay, off.
Uh-uh.
Off, off.
You're out of alignment.
You two are out of alignment.
Hey, that's a good one.
That is a really good one.
I like that one.
High IQ, highest IQ.
And velar.
Not really.
I screen shot the crate image in Marshmallow.
Okay.
What are we doing? I'm doing a little...
guess the difference.
Hi, pretty kitty.
I don't know why, but cats really like when they're...
I got pet them in rhythm of the...
You mean your tail pet?
That's not really, like, feels too much.
You mean your chest pet?
You mean your ears?
Okay.
You mean your feetsies pet?
Is that all the space?
Okay.
Oh, sorry. You mean your chin pet?
You're a temperamental little fuck, you know that?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I just keep head pounding?
Oh.
I was literally...
over-complicating that.
That was not too early.
Okay, the speed is changing, which is why my brain...
Yeah, the speed is changing.
You fuck.
Yeah.
They're changing the speed right at the end.
So my eyes are like, okay, if I...
maintain that speed, that's what it...
Yeah, fuck off.
We did it?
Mr. Mittens is happy?
He's gonna claw you?
Oh, you're so happy.
I love happy eating.
Wow.
Is this it, J.G.?
We did it!
Oh, he's actually peeing.
Oh, we got, like, a little animation.
A little animation?
You're feeling very sleepy, Rachel.
Oh, they're, like, synchronized swimmers!
I can't interact with...
nice detail, I see it.
Oh, no.
I'm not just enjoying the credits,
or am I actually to do something here?
I don't know if this is the credit.
I'm supposed to do something.
I can't click on anything.
Oh, I can.
Can I shake his butt?
I can click on me.
Everyone, let me...
I'm trying to, like, drag them.
They're the only things I can grab.
Oh, right.
Okay, okay, okay, D.
Why did you stop? I drink...
I take a swig of cola and you all stop?
Right, keep doing... yeah, keep...
Why are you retained so slowly now?
You're keeping me up.
Who's out of alignment? Identify yourself.
I can't touch anyone.
Huh?
No one's letting me touch them.
Don't you shake your little butts at me.
Nothing is letting me interact with it.
Two of them, please.
I can't grab any of them, though.
I don't know if you can hear me
spam-clicking in the background.
Emmy's rat army merch win.
No one's letting me touch them
literally at the convention
when you guys realize I'm the sexist.
I saw an image, actually.
I was going to tweet it out
and it was a picture of a woman
putting her hands in
a guy's pants and I was going to tweet out
like me at the convention for real.
When I see you for real, for real,
but I was like, oh god, that's not going to get me in trouble.
I am clicking
everything that will let me touch it.
I kid you not, I am going absolutely not.
I think I might have glitched it.
I don't know if I should rethought
something. I don't think it calibrated
right in this instance
because I'm
absolutely clicking it otherwise
and there's nothing hiding behind my head.
If you did that, you'd be good.
Who's going to get in trouble? Management?
What's that? No HR.
Right, I'm going to reset
because I'm not sure
that's working.
Oh no, don't make me pass it again.
One,
two,
three, uh uh,
four, uh uh, five,
six,
seven,
eight,
nine,
32 pets.
You learned it here first.
Sleep.
What is that thing? Don't ask for permission.
Ask for forgiveness. Real.
Real.
I maybe get six in a row.
Right, what did I do? I spun him over
for a little bit.
We did the one thing.
Okay.
Can you go start shaking your booty?
Oh, yeah, I bogged out.
What happens if they all kiss
and love each other?
No, they're kissing.
Oh,
I understand.
Sorry.
Oh my god, it's fun to
with this.
You will understand that reference
soon.
Okay.
Is this like a mini version
of all the puzzles I just
said?
I think it is.
Nuts and bolts and bolts and
nuts.
Nuts and nuts and bolts and bolts
and nuts.
You, you're upside down.
You're upside down too.
Oh, my brain can't.
What?
I was driving.
Oh,
actually.
Oh, who's not moving
in the rhythm?
A bug.
Oh, a little lady bird.
Well, multiple lady birds.
I'll know this fish again.
No, I'm not having it.
Yeah.
There we go.
A lady bird, yeah.
No, boo.
A lady bird.
You're pretty-ish?
Yeah, they're called lady birds.
Oh, my god, we're getting taken away the night.
What is it? What are we getting?
Oh, I like this one.
Oh, sorry.
Oh, give me more.
Whatever that was.
I'll take 19 more.
No questions asked.
I'll take it back.
Okay, there we go.
What?
Oh, my god.
Oh, my god, please.
More.
A lady bird.
Good.
No.
A bird.
Okay.
Oh, it's a sandwich. It's a lunchbox.
Get rid of the crumbs. Go away.
Oh, the crumbs stay.
Oh, the crumbs stay!
Put them...
Oh, the crumbs would go with the bread.
Maybe that makes more sense.
Reflings, look away at one.
Why is that wrong?
Oh, fuck off.
You didn't see that.
You didn't see it, Reflings. You didn't see it.
Is that crongo? Give me that crongo.
The bread.
The asparagus layman?
Misalignment and asparagus number three.
You cannot proceed. Do not collect your...
Oops, sorry.
Don't look!
A carrot? What?!
I'll get a grip.
What? How?
What's that?
What do you want?
What do you want from me?
Who are you? Who are they?
Okay, this is getting a bit ridiculous.
Sorry. Right, cherry, lemon, tomato and asparagus on the bottom.
Wait, what?
Everything I've done is, like, horrifically wrong.
I'm not being trolled. Wait, I'm being trolled.
The carrot refuses to go up and down.
They're refusing to go up and down.
Oh, god.
Mm-hmm.
Right.
Okay.
We did it.
Sorry, I understood what you meant. I'm jolly.
Thank you for your infinite patience for me, however.
I love strongy style.
Okay.
Is that supposed to mess that up at the end there?
Wait, the ending doesn't let you do it properly?
Oh, putters! Hi, putters!
Hi, yeah.
Bleep, bleep, bleep!
Lost the lid to the upper room.
Oh, we need to help you claim, darling. How do I do that?
Okay, give me that one.
No, get rid of that. Give me that one.
Okay. New level.
Oh.
Okay, please stop.
Mm-hmm.
Uh-huh, mm-hmm, mm-hmm. Okay, mm-hmm.
Yes, yes.
I'm slaying.
I'm slaying, truly.
Truly in wholeheart, like, slaying.
I need another toe one!
Okay, he needs just the wee one now.
There you go. Wee!
Are you doing it, buddy?
You're going for the moon.
I don't even know that one.
Let's do a toe.
Yep. Nope.
Yep.
Mm-hmm.
Wee-yep.
Then a little one.
Then a little small one.
Then an even skinnier, malincier one.
Yeah, I'm windy.
I'm windy, okay.
I don't know why it's jiggling.
What, can I only do wee one?
Oh, I can't remove it.
Don't let me add it.
I need to, like, fucking label block one.
The game's actually making sweat work!
Let's go high.
It won't let me remove, so...
Give me a wee skinny one!
It doesn't like that one a lot.
But it doesn't want me to remove it.
I don't want to remove it.
That one a lot.
But it doesn't like anything else either.
It only is the second wee one.
That was rather bizarre.
Hydration check.
Evil hydrate.
Honestly, I'd rather...
I'd rather...
Because it's not being mean.
Like, it's not like it's not cycling through it.
No, don't start wobbling again.
You're so dramatic.
I'm losing a little bit.
Just a little bit.
I need a wee one.
A wee short one.
There's a wee short one.
Aye, two wee short ones, I'll do that.
And then, like, the...
These wee medium ones.
Nope.
Yep.
No, then it'll lean into a piece of me.
That's correct.
I'm not sure what the requirements are.
Is it, like, the colour scheme thing?
Is it too high?
It has the colour match?
Don't see such things.
What is that?
Oh, it does have the colour match!
Why would you do such a thing?
Am I supposed to just wait for yellow only then?
Oh, my God, you're so right, is...
And then I need a skinny red one.
No, like a wee one.
Yeah!
Oh, close enough.
Kind of.
Right, I need a wee wee wee.
A wee wee red one.
To say red in French, you say...
You say pink in French, you say...
What colour is this thing called?
I can't believe I didn't figure that out.
So you're telling me I was just getting lucky this entire time?
I believe it.
I just need a long one.
I need a long one and then I can put a wee one on it.
Long!
Or two mediums.
I'll take it.
Beak.
Play, dee-play.
What do we do?
Grey?
You've given me grey, so why not?
I don't know, it's too big.
Complete the timer by using every available spot.
Done?
Where there's the cat under the tree.
Under the moon and he's fleeing with it like it's yarn.
Then the cat is over the moon
and he's purring in the moon.
Thank you for listening to my song about the cat.
Now knock it over.
Honestly, cat behaviour.
What an interesting game.
Cat is ascending in the air.
Wah, a cozy completion.
Complete the campaign mode.
That was actually so surprisingly nice.
Oh well, I get to be the cat now.
Oh my god, Anne McMillan.
How could we have done that without you?
Lucas, don't forget we didn't have you near about you as well.
We're messing it all up.
What, I honestly thought...
I'm gonna say something really mean.
I thought that was gonna be rubbish.
But it was, Ney.
It was actually really good.
So is VV right or wrong?
Controversial take?
Is that Australian VTuber was wrong?
I thought that was gonna be rubbish.
But I really enjoyed that.
I don't know, what do you think?
Have you played it?
And if you haven't played it, did you...
Did I make you want to give it a shot?
It's like one of those games where you can tune out to this.
Other than the fridge one.
Sorry, I'm writing a review on the fridge one.
I don't care.
That fridge one makes no sense.
They need to make it more obvious.
I said what I said.
VV, actually VV was wrong.
Congrats.
We're gonna have to tune back.
No.
Might not stand up to many people.
No, you can replay it.
No.
A good start to a game.
Definitely.
I think that's definitely for more casual VTubers
that don't necessarily need something hyper intense.
They just want to have a nice chat and enjoy the experience.
I'd say that was pretty dang bandabi-dosey, honestly.
Never forget to paint the tools.
Now, I will say, I suspect VV never actually checked the hints.
VV and strongy drama confront?
No.
I'm gonna guess she purposely did it where she didn't look at the hints.
Because I looked at the hints, obviously I was like, well, I know what to do.
It was actually mostly fun because you played it.
Love the kit.
I was just so worried when I'm like, oh no, it may be a boring game.
These things might not find me.
VV actively avoided the hints function because she's a completionist.
Ah yes, okay.
I suspected that because with the hints then you can make it work.
You could do it in the future to get the solutions you want.
Do you want to play more puzzle games?
You could try the Talos principle.
I found it tough.
Oh, I'm very dumb.
It's super fun.
The alternative solutions on some of these are wild.
The game works pretty well if you can borrow brain cells.
Literally, thank you for carrying me.
Thank you so much for stream sniping.
Oh no, it's not called stream sniping.
It's called backseat gaming.
I love backseat gaming.
Ah, please do it more to me.
Sorry, I'm stretching when I did that.
So I got really late there.
Sorry if I scared anyone.
I did a stretch.
I switched.
I did big switch.
Oh, nowhere.
Are these all the creator's pets?
I'm going to agree.
That's so wholesome.
I love it.
Honestly, I'm going to say something controversial.
10 out of 10.
Sorry, it was.
That was such a good experience.
You've got a cute little lane where the cat is winding you up through the whole thing.
Controversial, but 10 out of 10.
Literally, I didn't expect that.
Have you ever played Catherine?
No, but I'm aware of it.
And I know it's a puzzle game and there's no chance I'm going to win without dying.
So I would get too frustrated and start screaming at the game and then close it.
I think you're guessing a bit too much.
You didn't like that.
Maybe you guys made it really enjoyable for me, but I found that rather pleasant gaming experience.
Now, there's not many games that you can describe as pleasant.
And this, I would say, was such a pleasant environment.
The music, the little plot of her little pudders, annoying as, you know, I thoroughly enjoyed that.
Maybe you made it more enjoyable than I originally would rate it if I was just on my own some lonesome, but that was, I enjoyed that.
I don't think it was bad, but it's not 10 out of 10.
When you think of a game, you have to remove what you want to see in a game.
Because I would ask you, if you don't rate it at 10 out of 10, what would you do to improve it?
And you have to be careful with that question, because if what you're going to do to improve it would completely change up what the core purpose of the game is,
which is kind of relaxing, kind of puzzler environment.
And it's not really environment, because you're not really 3D, are you?
Like, did the development team achieve what they wanted to achieve with this game?
I would say, yes, they hit the nail on the head, it's a 10 out of 10.
You're relaxed, you're playing puzzles.
Yeah, it gets a bit frustrating, but they've literally got the hints ready right for you to be like, hey, we've got this.
Now, yeah, we ran into like, I think, what, two unpolished bugs?
Rather than that.
Who's this?
It was pleasant to what you played.
Johnny, it's a 10 out of 10.
Yeah, also me with Edith Finch.
Yeah, 8 out of 10, yeah.
Yeah, that's terrible.
I have a rubbish rating system, okay?
Well, you did already criticise the fridge puzzle.
Yes, now, whether or not that's a...
I'm going to, like, if I look it up and everyone agrees that the fridge puzzle needs a bit of alteration, then sure.
It depends how you rate games.
Well, you can't go, you can't rate a game objectively.
Right, this sounds really sad, but I want to rate video games in the future, and like, I did my research...
I did my research, I'll shut the fuck up, Johnny.
I researched it into it, and like, you have to remove your bias, because if you were to compare this game to Call of Duty,
yeah, of course it's a resident sleeper game.
You have to judge the game based on what the game is giving you.
You have to remove your bias as well, because my preference is, like, you know, something exciting,
but I don't want to get stalled in the progress type thing.
But I need to read... I need to remove my bias in a game type. Does that make sense?
Makes sense?
We need an expert game journal.
I'm going to attempt to do a review on Assassin's Creed Brotherhood,
and then a review on Isaac as my Donathon Rewards.
Now, in before, they're just absolutely catastrophic failures, but I want to give it a chance.
You need to compare it to other puzzlers in the genre.
Stick to the genre. You need to kind of, like, be able to identify what the dev team we're going for,
did they achieve it, you know, all these kind of things.
Finally, yapping is back. Stop!
Catastrophic. I've always wanted to be a game critic, but that's how I review games.
Yes. Attempting to have an objective eye is a good instinct, but impossible.
Hold those both in your head and you'll be fine.
Yes, so like, obviously, I'll be biased.
I'll be like, Assassin's Creed Brotherhood, 10 out of 10, best game of all time.
I've missed out if you have not played it. The graphic, you know, does the game live up to a dated, you know, time period and all that?
Actually, yes. But then again, I have a personal bias, and when I review the game, I'll say that I have an insane personal bias
because it also has a nostalgic factor for me.
Nostalgia is a billion dollar industry.
Billion dollar for nostalgia, okay?
The emotional nostalgia cannot be artificially recreated.
You must have experienced it at a younger age to create the pathways in your brain of familiarity.
You didn't know your brain adores familiarity.
It is not like going out of its way to learn new things because that takes effort, that takes brain power, that takes, you know, motivation to learn, take things.
That is why nostalgia is an insane drug that cannot be created in a lab.
I could go on a big massive rant about how powerful the nostalgia is.
You know, for example, you see this meme in passing.
When you get, like, a whiff of your childhood and, like, you walk past somewhere and you can, like, smell your childhood and you get, like, flashed back
and you never get the flash again because you don't know what the smell was type thing, okay?
You know what I mean?
Honest life, yeah.
But that's my teaching about it.
Nostalgia in the next teaching stream?
Uh, yeah, I wouldn't mind doing that at all.
I think I may stop the teaching stream just a little bit though.
Just a little bit.
But that's okay.
You usually want to stream or play this.
I check it out to see their experience with it, but they eventually have it in the background.
One of the camera streams for this.
I'd be more interested and curious.
I was only camp because I knew you guys would carry me through the game.
You guys would tell me smell and memory near the place of the rain.
Are you listening to an old song?
The teaching was fun.
Literally first day that's joining in goes for four hours.
Star has already been four hours.
I won't, no, I'll ramble for a bit, but I can't.
Is Emmy coming on?
We can maybe redirect into Emmy.
When does Emmy come on?
Sorry, the background music's gonna dissipate.
Oh, Emmy, are you coming on to this, darling?
Are you coming?
Sorry.
Shut the fuck up.
I'm so excited.
Sorry.
I'm so excited to just be back doing long streams again.
I'm sorry.
That was wildly inappropriate.
Oh, stop.
I'm getting excited.
I've literally just played a puzzle game and I'm like, oh, not today.
Okay, I'm on my own some lonesome today.
Well, we can just be in San Juman.
I'm so so so.
Stonny's energy is coming back.
That's it.
Any more energy?
Oh, my YouTube short about how much does a small agency make?
It got one out of ten.
Oh my God.
And you guys are liking it.
Hold on.
Oh, I'm accidentally recording my screen eat.
I hate when my PC does that.
I try.
I do a screenshot and then it's like screen recording everything.
And I'm like, bro, can you not?
Hold on.
See this PC?
I'm actually gonna fart in its mouth.
This is such a rubbish PC.
Oh, that's a bit big.
You know what else is big?
Mal willy.
Sorry.
I'm so excited to be able to do longer streams again.
And I know I've got shorter streams for tomorrow and the other day.
Mercy's streaming at 10 a.m. my time or your time?
Because it's 7 a.m. right now.
I'm not sure I can yet.
Can I really yet?
Can I yet for two more hours?
Sadly no little sister there.
The shortest of one out of ten.
Right.
Okay.
So as you see on the screen, ranking by views, it says one out of ten.
That means in my last ten uploads of whatever content, this has ranked the highest in like
most generated views in the time span.
Okay.
So it's a one out of ten.
This is a really big thing.
Okay.
It means, hey, hold on a minute.
This is doing really well in comparison to previous uploads type thing.
So and then it says, so you see how that green dot is that green arrow on views is up.
That means again, I've gained more views.
Ten noon.
Noon.
I can't ramble for three hours.
I need to save my voice because I'm recording pregnancy.
It's so hard tonight and all my collabs are missed out on.
So I can.
But yeah.
Well, number go up.
I don't know about the Willy but the cake is massive.
Okay.
But yeah, it did well.
Thank you for everyone who interacted with that short.
I'm just checking the comments and someone's like, how much does your agency take?
How much does the agency take from me?
And even if I was a talent, it's 80, 20 and next year goes to 85, 15.
So the company see this.
The company see this.
It's so hyper.
Sorry.
I'm sure you're sick of me.
I'll put my background music on.
But yeah.
Thank you everyone who interacted with that short.
You're super kill and awesome.
And thank you for looking into my finances for me.
Thank you for looking into the gen two finances.
What?
Who said that?
No, but really 12 cases massive for the first month for a beginning agency.
Yeah.
I am very lucky.
Just like how everything worked out.
Like obviously when I was brewing the girls in my womb, I was like, oh my God.
Am I making a mistake?
Like is this insane?
No motherfucker.
This ain't insane.
This is my calling motherfucker.
I have daughters.
I get to support and they get to achieve their dreams of being content creators.
This is my calling in life.
Just give me what should we do karaoke?
I'm being so for real right now.
Should we do pop up karaoke?
Hold on.
We could essentially do pop up karaoke for like two hours.
And then we can redirect into mercy.
I think we could.
Oh.
Oh no.
I have to save my voice.
No.
I forgot.
I need to do ASMR.
No.
I need to record ASMR.
Okay.
Wait.
We'll do another pop up in another day.
I need to do ASMR.
I forgot.
I have so many people waiting for me to record ASMR to upload my collapse.
I'm so sorry.
I can't sing.
I'm so sorry to get excited.
Get you excited.
I'm done.
Please forgive me.
Right.
Let me open up my marshmallow.
Don't you have that kind of stream layer in the week?
Yeah.
But I like doing lots of streams.
I'm never offline.
That's right.
That's why I make the big bucks.
Because I'm never offline.
Wow.
If you want to save money for the girls, you could link your accounts together with the
Steam Family feature.
Yes.
The girls have full permission to do that with their previous accounts.
And they get to keep their Steam accounts at the end of their...
I don't know when they want to depart.
I don't keep it.
That's their money.
I absolutely do not touch any of that because they spent their money on it.
So they own it.
Crazy.
Hi, Duan.
Hi, Leiflin.
I watched some of you a little to the left stream.
What do you...
And I may have misheard you, but it sounded like you're not doing too well.
Oh, no.
Sorry.
My dad has gone home.
When I said I'm depressive, espresso.
What I meant is my dad's gone home.
So I'm sad, but I'm happy because I get to hang out with you.
You know, it cancels out the sadness.
As soon as I click end broadcast, it's fucking over for me.
That's all I'm saying.
I'm going to go cry in the bath.
I'm not even kidding.
I'm going to fully shave because I'm so fucking hairy.
Anonymous, Johnny.
Get us worked up then leaving us hanging.
That's cruel.
I'm so sorry.
I didn't mean it, Leiflin.
I got distracted.
My dad went home, so I'm sad.
Yeah, crying will record in the ASMR.
Honestly, though, we could always have Twitter spaces.
I'm going to say something so controversial.
I don't like Twitter.
I like putting my projects on Twitter being like, hey, I'm recording pregnancy ASMR.
Here's a picture.
Hey, I'm doing this with someone here.
I don't actually like the concept of Twitter and being like, hi, I'm in the bath, shaving
my hairy minge.
What am I supposed to tweet?
I don't get it.
In another life, I was basically forced to tweet every day and I was like, oh, I don't
like it.
I don't like it.
Please quit me right now.
You know?
Be happy.
Thank you, Kairon.
It's like TMI.
It's just no for me.
Oh my gosh.
Is that the Fibonacci sequence card from the hit video game, Baltro?
Thank you for the five gifted memberships math, 16, 18.
And congrats to those who caught it without this.
No, don't shave.
You're so pretty.
You're so pretty when I can't see the forest for the trees.
Twitter spaces are great.
The brain world is already here.
It's back, baby.
Hydration chip.
Okay.
I'll finish reading that, Maro.
But I'm sorry.
No, don't worry.
I promise.
Hopefully you know all the reeflings here about you and wish nothing but the best.
Yes, I'm so sorry to confuse you, reefling.
Please don't worry about me.
When I said I'm upset, it's because my dad's gone home.
And I love my dad very much.
And he's a hoot and a holler.
And it's very nice to have him around.
But the next time I'll see him is probably in like two years time, which was a bit rough.
It was like, ah, shit.
That's a rough name.
He said he doesn't think he can come on the plane next year to come see me, to come visit me.
And now he would come visit me if I asked.
If I said quit your fucking job right now and come over for like three months, then he would 100% do it.
So please don't worry.
It's not like that.
It's just it's most likely two years.
Like I showed my dad everything, like what I do work wise on that.
And he said hi to AC.
I don't know if I said it in the other stream, but don't worry if you weren't there.
He said hi to AC.
I was invoiced that way.
He could through just hanging out.
And I was like, oh, I was like, oh, dad, dad, dad, dad.
This is AC.
Say Privyat.
And he was like, what?
I was like, yeah, Privyat.
It means hello in Russian.
Go Privyat.
And he was like, Privyat.
And AC couldn't hear it sadly.
But we were having a goof over.
I was showing him my work.
I was like, so this is what I do for the girls and all of that.
And he was like 20%.
And I'm like, yep, 20%.
I don't want to be greed.
I'm anti-greed.
And he's like, yep, yep.
That sounds right.
That sounds about you, Johnny.
Did AC call him dad?
Don't.
No.
You're done.
I'm farting on your eyelashes.
Open up your eyeballs right now.
Don't ever say that again.
Hi, Johnny.
Serious answer here.
OK.
Emmy and Laura is ginger.
But in her VTuber model, it's definitely more blonde.
And tell her she's ed in.
She is ed in her model, actually.
She is alternate in...
Emmy is so fantastic to work with.
Oh my God.
We like came to an agreement.
She's like, I think you guys have seen it.
So I'm allowed to talk about it.
And if she doesn't want me to talk about it.
Sorry, Emmy.
I love you.
I'll pay you 50 bucks to not be mad at me.
Emmy...
So Emmy's designed her 2.0.
But I had to say to her.
I love your 2.0.
But you need to let Emmy 1.0 be a thing for a little bit longer.
So we came to an agreement that she's going to get fixed up a little bit
to Emmy's image, which I'm 100% OK with.
Like, as I said, I want the girls to be happy with who they are.
Because at the end of the day, they've been given models, OK?
Like, Shebe, she's already told you.
Shebe's getting a more reflective version of herself on a model.
That's coming out soon to you.
I don't know when.
Nari's cooking.
Nari's cooking very hard right now.
She's a very busy modeler.
So please do have patience, but yes.
It's a 1.5 model.
She showed it on stream.
Yes, as I said, I'm Emmy, not Emily.
Did I say Emily?
Wait, why are you guys saying Emily?
I did.
It must have started because in a mashed words together, you didn't.
OK, Emmy, Emmy, Emmy.
Emmy, Emmy, yeah, Emmy, yeah, Emmy, yeah.
Drank.
Swalalala.
But yes, as I said, I'm happy for the girls to, you know,
change things up and look the way they want.
But I do need her to still be very close to the original design,
and she was so good to work with.
Like I was passing on messages from the concept artists to each other
and being like, OK, you can do this, but don't do this,
because you need this and don't do that, because you need that.
And she was so good.
She was also so good to work on, so 10 out of 10.
Work with, sorry, on an objective.
On an objective.
And he looked, fuck, I'm dying.
Sorry, I just choked on my spit.
I'm trying to like talk and breathe and like swallow my spit at the same time,
because I'm so excited to get the next question out, OK?
He found a good bunch of daughters.
Bro, they found me.
I don't know how on earth they were crazy enough to go for it.
Bro, crazy.
But they did it.
And here we are.
I mean, fuck, here we are.
We're almost at like all of us are 10,000T subs.
I'm so excited to release that motherfucking artwork.
Oh, my God.
Oh, my God, AC is almost 8K.
Oh, my God, I'm humping to death.
Hmm.
Wow.
And AC and Emmy have a collab coming out soon on AC's channel.
Sometimes when you get me bricked off, it doesn't go down for an hour.
Oh, no, four hours is dangerous.
Are you based on strong heim?
Strongest strong heim.
Sounds a bit familiar.
Oh, I am based after strontium, which is my dad's gamer tag, not the actual gamer tag
before you look up and be like, I find her dad relax.
It's not the actual gamer tag.
But unbelievably, actually, so we are debuts got clipped on this channel called smoothie
and someone replied under my comment and they were like, are you after strontium dog?
So this is the even more hidden lore behind my name.
So strontium dog is a comic my dad used to read.
And then he made his gamer tag like strontium.
It's not exactly strontium, so relax.
And then I called myself strontium.
And someone commented under and said, are you after strontium dog?
And I'm like, yes, what the eff.
The fact even you what strontium dog was was insane.
It was literally gone full circle.
Full circle.
Okay.
Throw that ass in a full circle.
And sorry, I'm super hyper today.
I fucking might be so much worse ones.
It's so nice to just not feel like stress.
Now, I love my dad.
Love me dad.
Love me refund.
Simple.
I felt like I was juggling a lot like normally a nap after streaming all of that.
And all of that jazz.
I'm almost caught up with the Elden Ring streams.
They start up in like two weeks again.
So I hope you're all Elden.
I hope you've got like your Elden Ring barfool.
Can't wait for your dad to be announced in gen two.
Oh my God.
That would be hilarious.
Hi guys, strontium here.
I would play the clip that I recorded with him, but he said my legal name in it.
I was like, I was like, I would just record in it so you can see what you want.
So instantly goes legal name.
And I'm like, okay, well, I'll need to edit that before I send it on to the editors.
And strontium's dad is going to be the best girl.
Oh my God.
The only male allowed on stream for real for real.
I managed to catch up to Elden Ring so he can help you out.
Oh yeah.
Go kiss me on your lips.
I'm going to help me in the flower field.
Sensor the name.
Bro, honestly.
We need a model for strontium's dad if he ever comes on a stream.
So we recorded a short of him guessing VTuber names.
And I said to him, if it goes viral, you realize you're going to have to get shipped out again so we can record more.
We would make him our Oshi.
Strontium.
The dad tubers, honestly.
No, my immersion.
That's my fucking dad.
No, don't troll when it comes to that.
I know idol culture, no male on stream.
But if I'm like, yeah, my dad.
That's my dad, okay?
Then he started making me get raged.
Then he made me enraged.
Dad tuber, real.
Since you're a cutfish, your dad model needs to be cracking.
Well, I'm going to get a doodle of him drawn for the shorts because when he talks, obviously it was just me sitting there staring at the screen.
But I need to like, who goes there?
I need to cut up the audio and then I need to get an insane amount of assets.
The short is going to cost so much money to get.
I mean, Strontium's dad is already in my kami Oshi.
You have a father.
I thought you were a cutfish.
Wait, cutfishes don't have dads.
Cutfishes don't have dads.
Are you getting me to type something into Google that makes no sense?
No.
First question that comes up.
Can you keep a cutfish as a pet?
Oh, whoa.
No, they're too smart.
Don't do it.
Wait, does that mean he would get a Patreon as a...
Stop!
Stop.
They definitely do have male progenitors.
Some people are that parasocial.
I bloody hope not when my fucking dad were...
I'm going to start fighting hands with the shadow people again.
It's been a day since my dad's gone and I'm already throwing hands with the shadow people.
Actually, you know what's really disgusting?
I've instantly stopped taking showers every morning and I know that he's gone.
Like, absolute minger.
Absolute minger.
Hi, Strontium.
Don't want to make you cry earlier or anything.
Don't worry.
It's reserved for the bath time.
But you're a wonderful goober and we'll never get sick of it.
If you're ever sad, we're here for you.
If you ever need help, we're here for you.
If you're ever raging hard, we're here to get our worded by you.
Strontium, love maxing.
We fling, love maxing.
Get kissed, get kissed, get kissed.
I just forced my tongue in your mouth when I go...
Honestly, that's terrible.
Let's see if that turns out okay.
Dude, Papa Cuttle's leave as a message.
Yes, he did, but I can't read it or I'm going to burst out crying.
I need to give it a few days before I be there.
But the TLDR is thanks for looking after my daughter whilst I couldn't.
And that's all I'm going to say before I start crying.
Hi, Strontium.
Hi, Bethling.
You and the rest of the girls are really inspiring.
Oh, yeah, you're inspired by the autism of your honor.
Thank you very much.
I wanted to be a content creator too.
Oh, yeah.
Come aboard.
Clam aboard.
Oh, no, I doubt I'll ever do an interesting audio.
Oh my god.
Shock and behavior.
I can't believe it.
You don't want to moan into the microphone.
But I was way too afraid or too busy.
But after seeing you guys have so much fun.
I want to do it too today.
I've been making original songs.
Oh my god, you can make the cat songs from...
You should play straight and then give the music man these music sheets
and then make songs off the top of your head.
I find it crazy that Carl Fish is motivating me
to get back to what I did this.
Thanks for pumping me up.
You got to know.
Pump it up.
We got to pump it up.
We got to know.
Now let me pump your clam with my ink.
Okay.
You're done.
You're done, though.
Done.
Well, if you can write diss tracks, let me know.
Because I want the girls to do diss tracks on each other.
I think that's the funniest thing ever.
Oh, strongy cuddles.
More like strongy fumbles the bag.
Because what's with that 80-20 cut?
You literally are not going to get a yacht at that rate.
Whoa.
I can go straight, honestly.
That's what I need.
I so badly want diss tracks.
I want to, like, diss track.
Be a little bit more, like, feel the whores.
Stop.
That's not funny.
Hi, strongy.
Hi, refling.
I love you so much.
Sorry.
I'm getting so excited.
I'm at 10.
I need to turn it down to a 7.
Okay.
Hi, strongy.
Hi, refling.
I don't mind if you don't shit.
Replay.
Also, don't shower so I can taste you.
Napoleon Bonaparte back from the grave.
Jeez.
I'll rip your bones apart.
Bonaparte.
Turn your horse into glue.
That is a reference to horses being turned into glue.
That is an actual thing.
Hi, strongy.
Hi, refling.
You know, I want you to get comforted.
Get comforted.
Pop, pop, pop, pop.
Comfort, comfort, comfort.
Will we ever get a horror game stream?
Yeah.
Technically, yes.
I'm very scared of horror games.
I scream in them and I have a heart rate monitor.
So, yes.
Eventually, it's probably going to be like a Donoth on reward because I get freaked out
in video games.
I get really good immersion when I play video games where I have tunnel vision and stuff.
So, that makes the first person horror games 10 times scarier because I feel like they're
going to touch my freaking back.
FNAF 1 would absolutely make me shit myself.
I'm not even kidding.
The chair would be ruined.
What was that person thinking?
I bet if I melted that horse, I could stick things together.
Can I teach you something?
They most likely were cooking the horse and then they were like, oh, it went really sticky.
That's weird.
And then it did it to another horse and then it went sticky and then it went another horse
and then it went sticky and then they realized they could make glue from it.
It's kind of like the cow drinking thing.
People were like, eh, he was the first human to figure out that cows get milk.
Motherfucker, you were breastfed.
Humans and mammals ain't that different.
Well, actually, I'm going to shit your pants right now.
Wait, no, I'm not going to shit your pants right now.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Wait, let me restart.
Humans are mammals.
Babies drink milk from boob.
Boob is also on cow.
Cow produces milk.
It's not some weird thing where a random guy taught cow in a field and went, oh, let me get some of that.
No, it was domestication of animals.
No, I'm not shitting your pants.
I'm sorry.
No, I didn't mean that.
Shit your pants.
NO!
Honestly anonymous ain't no way my Aussie is interested in epic rap battles in history
Are you kidding me? I love that stuff, although I definitely haven't watched the newest stuff at all
Be gentle in your panty lin
What is she cooking something devious clearly? I just want a fresh pair who's gonna clean them your problem not mine. Oh
No, hold on I'm about to be proven wrong live on stream
I
Don't know I'm getting your reference sheets for the girls. Don't show me that
Don't show me that right. I'll be fair. I've even sent me the reference sheets of the girls. I'm getting your ones for them
If you want to save money, oh, I read that one. Oh my god. I'm out of our club. Hi. I'm new here to all this VTuber stuff
All right, I was just making sure you weren't asking anything
Okay, but I was hoping you could answer a few questions. I'm sorry if you answered them
Oh, yeah, of course. I wondered if there's a place where you will post your karaoke streams
I'll be working most likely when you miss it. Oh, I don't host it myself
And normally archive annons do it all for me. Thank you archive annons. You are the secret hidden people of the good stuff
Thank you. We appreciate you and
Yes, hopefully you don't mind if I ask but how would we know if something like cat rocks is broken? Oh
You just need to replace dot with the word dot and then I'll do the rest
If you want to send it, I'll just say link archive annons are the seventh member of veal or literally they work in over time
Their PCs are exploding
And fucking there they're they start quaking when Azura has a fucking legal edge and streams
They're little their knees are noblin. That's all I'm saying
They're noblin and wobbling in their chair when they see you on the schedule that Azura's got legal edge and strings
They're like no, my my fucking PC is gonna implode
So far you only had one members carry
Just a little
I'll always be here for you and so will the roof and stop being so wholesome to me. How dare you?
Stop being so
Hi strongy, you are correct. I'm a is a hundred percent doing ginger. Thank you
But you are wrong about Azura her hair is green
It's similar to Hatsune Miku
You're gonna shit your pants when you learn what color hats and Miku's hair is that's fucking blue. She's bloody blue
You say cutfish candy be pits, but what about you? Oh, right? Okay. That was good. That was smooth. Okay. Let's do a let's do a
I need a clap I need like a round of applause. I'll get round of applause, okay
Back in the pants again when I learned she was a league player. I was like what but you're friendly
But you're nice blue hair blue tie hiding in your Wi-Fi
Open secret
I'm thinking me
Buzzer's hair is Prismarine. I've never seen that word in my life. Hey
Marine I'm literally typing in piss marine right now. Is this a joke? Is it gonna be a willy? Oh my god, it's a minecraft block
I'm so sorry. I don't play I have I have really limited knowledge on minecraft
Prismarine is a minecraft block
What is prismarine in real life prismarine is entirely entirely fictional
However, it looks like aquamarine. Right. Okay an aqua blue meaning war
That's right. Thank you. It's seafoam. I swear. I don't know is her concept
I
Forgot to send away her concept art. So I need to do that
Hi strongy you mentioned you want to make a diss track for veiler. I just find them so goofy and fun
Sorry, I do what the crazy is I was thinking that a while ago making your own version of your background music
Be and then writing lyrics about the six you get on my head
You silly cut fish I want to get in the studio right now pop pop pop get in the studio pop pop pop
Hasimiko here is officially blue green. No, it's not. It's blue. She's blue
All right, I'm about to head out. Good night. Racewell reeflings. Sorry. I keep yapping. I
Need to go take a vocal rest and then I need to go edit or maybe I'll not and
Then I'll edit and then I'll record pregnant with you
But rest
Hi, mommy. I heard you like epic rap battles, but generally you say your favorite minors
Definitely Steve Jobs versus Bill Gates. I actually really like the Leonardo
The Leonardo one the fucking Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles versus the Renaissance ones
Because although I didn't realize they were named after Renaissance characters until I watched that epic rap battle
Because I was like the orange again. I guess names of my curse my color something like that
No, good night. Those who rest Ronnie good night, Ronnie. Wait, are you guys sending me off? What the fuck?
No, I'm saying good night to that reef Lynn. Are you sending me off?
Wait, am I a magical offline?
I'm actually I'm not being sent off wait. I was saying good night to that reef Lynn. Did I not say it in a sentence structure?
Oh
Yes, leave oh you're gonna put me in the bath so I can choose I'll do a shave in ASMR
Why not?
She could shake it like a party animal. I really want to play view of up in you. I'm so fucking excited to leave you
But yeah, I'm not even kidding
Leave up in yard filled with fun filled with fun
Oh
Sorry, I love putting my accent on when I sing it makes me laugh
If you don't go to bed right now lass you get no I nk for a week. No
Thank you tiny thingy. I
Mean I could I guess I could go for a nap rather than a bath. What are you doing? I don't know
What about this thing or it's still not on this PC. It's a mother PC. I'm so sorry
I'll show this thing or what do you want to see the outro? I can show you the outro right? Hold on. Boom. There you go
Actually can't hear the music so I don't know if I'm in time with anything, but look it's you on my head
Getting boycotted out. She's actually leaving got the sensors on I don't even think I have the uncensored version
Because I used this for debut and then I've never touched it since
From no, oh my god, right. I'm looking on who I'm gonna redirect into we're doing rare from and you me plus
She's playing Roblox dressed in press
What what I want to do that?
That's where we belong sat on mummy's head. Yeah
I don't want to you leave. Are you is your strontium copium not gone higher?
I think I got the uncensored version somewhere
Starting leaving us after only four hours of yapping. Wait, do you want like a few minutes more?
Hi, I
Never left. I'm sorry. I'm sorry to give you
Hi, is this bear
Oh
I'm sorry you can see the cursor in the background is actually capturing the cursor in game
Bonjour, please
Next week we're gonna test it out in a member stream just to make sure I've never used test.com or signed up and I don't want anything
Happening on it, so we're gonna test it in a member stream and then we're gonna do it as a public stream set, okay?
10 minutes of yapping my favorite
10 12 hours of yapping
I'm gonna fart. I fart so badly
Not gonna lie shaving ASMR might sound nice
Shaving what my legs are you not gonna be satisfied until you hear?
Mm-hmm the thing
Stop being wholesome
But it's hard when you're cute and came to reee
We just want to pat you give you kid give you kisses and cuddle and put your prints until you drill and steady on steady on on the edge on the edge
Maybe maybe
Hi, Stony
Underrated whichever for real Stony is so sex
What is that Japanese mean where that guy's just screaming sex in the tunnel I feel that
I'm
100% body shave ASMR ending on the clam that would take me so long to do like 20 minutes
kind of reefed
Takashi
that he grew up
Takashi chasing pedestrians and Takashi
Kashi's our spirit on the wall
Mmm
Sex and goofy is the real combo breaker. No Takashi your body won't handle it
Where he's on a bike I'm pretty sure he's on a bike in a tunnel and he's like sex out and it's like bouncing off the walls
Peak male perform him
Mummy I want you to know that about my first toy to fully enjoy your audio I had the best ink in my life so far
The corruption has begun and I'll never feel better than that
Only when you ink to me
welcome me I
Love when you get mindbroken without me even trying
Ah
Hi, Stony, why won't you show the side by side comparison I sent you what of me and she be
No
I'm getting up there
Get up there when she
That's what you get for
That's what you get for proving me slightly wrong you just get spat on I
Like how that's my default like oh you're mildly proving me wrong and
For your insolence you receive spit on your face should have been me
Honestly, yeah
Big stretch
Oh
King Kong what are you doing here my baby? I sound like tobacco more than King Kong. Hi, Stony. Hi. I've been edging
Okay, he almost inked if I didn't sorry I didn't I'm not reading ahead. Okay, I
Don't think he's doing it right now. It's okay, everyone. Don't be don't be nervous. It's not doing it right now. It's not doing it right now
You already corrupted me before you're strongy, but please corrupt me more love you
Yeah, I know what you're talking about. I've only been strongie smile. I'm a new content creator
I've never made content in my life smile
I
Shave whatever I think the sound may just be good. I won't complain. Oh, thank you. We've won
Let's see that we've learned. He's grateful. He's like, I'll get what I get and I'll be happy
Well, well trained refund and you have to break
Did I tell you the ASMR stream this is gonna be scripted for hypnosis I need to write it though
I have to use my brain strongy is strongy and it's never been anyone else true real
100% proof
Will we ever get collab patron only audios? Oh boy, you're gonna love August
AC and Emmy August
Merci and strongy August she be and is her August and before I already know people are gonna start fighting over the
Is your and she be one there's not only gonna be one collab audio ever in the existence of veal or fucking relax
If it's not for you, right? I wanted to make it and I made it. Okay
She's gone
Sure, here's kind of although. Yeah, you like that what I'm in in here
Hi, mummy. Do you want us to train for you until we can get what? No, no, this is the questions for another stream. Yeah, he's up
Hi, strongy. Here's my two cents on the hair color debate as there is hair color is literally
Translates the blue green and my lingo. So she's both Emmy is ginger. There's no debate. Thank you
Strongy, you're my kind of woman. Oh, yeah
I'm a huge joker and I'm known to push buttons
I feel like a fun poking at you until your Scottish rage comes out
I don't get angry like I don't get angry a person I get angry at like an animate object like video game
Does that make sense?
Then I'd give you head pads and kiss
Your pout is better and cuddle my little seaweed until she smiles. I don't get angry at people. I don't find it hard
Like, I don't know how to get angry at someone
Only thing I've worried about with
Is getting hair in the teeth
No, no, you're not you're not that no we don't we don't do that here
We don't do that here you can eat the peach but you're not eating the clam
Okay, the clam does not want any attention. Please leave the clam alone
I should play League of Legends with Azura if I want to get angry. I don't I can't even comprehend the game
I think I've seen gameplay of it three times and I can't comprehend it. I
Don't know what I'm doing. It's like an enemy has been slain. Well, yeah
I mean doesn't death occur in this game an ally has been slain. Well, yeah, lady like change
Well, everyone's supposed to survive no clam attention. They've been a bane another or the beans different
The the peril of the clam is different
Nobody could comprehend it at the start. I don't make sense Johnny's hair color is yet. I
Like my hair. I love the style of it, but I'm a sucker for bunches and symmetrical hair. I'm absolutely suffer for it
Do you want to just grab my pony tails from behind my little twin tails?
I do technically a twin tail and I like that is double bunches. You can't see it from the front
Well, I guess you kind of can I have double bunches behind my
Seashells I have a I have a ponytail at the seashells create that bump and then I have them at the bottom of the hair as well
So I have double bunches and I love it. I love it
Your sucker sure. Hope so
Twin tail handlebars. Yeah, I
Love it. I love it. I love oh
Yeah, no that reminded me something's like oh your character so ugly compared to everyone else. I'm like
Nice try me nice try. I'm pure six. You can admit it. It's fine
Only thing I'm worried about oh already read that. How do you oh my god? Oh my god, there's no more marshmallow questions, right?
I'm going offline good night
Anyone else in that? Oh, there's no marshmallow questions. I went offline instantly. How do you know?
Yeah, but the cake. Yes, your honor. Probably
You see that again. Go rest. I
Should rest and what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna go for a nap, okay?
And then I'm gonna go for a bath and then I'm gonna deal with all the backlog of work because the video game has been delayed
surprise surprise me who didn't
Fucked up, but it's fine. The game's still playable. That's the main thing and still one-handable if you want. Um, I
Need to hand over all the audio assets now. Um
Which is gonna take a hot second to edit but once it's done
It's one of those jobs that like I can tick off the list
It's not like a reoccurring job like at the moment the shorts with the girls are like reoccurring jobs and they kill me
Um, because like it's not like I can take it off a list or anything
Eh, if Mercy doesn't have a room up she's
Oh, no, I'm going into rare
It's not out yet. No, um
When are we getting the official news about the game? Um, the game is free
Um free access. It will be uh posted on the alternative twitters
It will not be posted from the main account due to the content
Like the main VLR account due to the content inside the game
Can you post that?
Can you post that now you can so
I mean, maybe we could
Do it announce it, but then link the girls all no no, it's too risky. It's too risky. I'm not risking. I'm not risking it
Uh, also the girls are getting access to fansly on august 1st, so
Do without what you will
I don't know what they're planning, but how about you? What kind of content?
One-handed gameplay content
So play with headphones. Yeah, definitely
Um getting the debit card ready
We will be there, but when are you gonna be on it? I need a bit more
Time and what I'm gonna purposely do is let the girls go ahead and do what they want to like get as much support for them
Because they actually get 100 of their
VLR don't take any cut from their bandslay at all
Um, so I'd rather they like get success and like more stabilized income if they want to do it
But I have requested them like hey remember
YouTube's your main income source like don't don't be cut. I said to them and actually you can quote this the girls will quote that
I said don't come to me with five bandsly streams on your schedule
And they all agreed and they said yeah, that's fine
Yeah, hold on. I'm hydrating
Don't feel send on bad. Yeah, I said look hey your income sources YouTube like then he didn't mess this up
And the price is going to be same completely up to the girl. We do not take any cut from
Uh
We do not take any cut so we don't dictate the price the girls pick their prices whatever they're happy with
And not up to be aware of the agency because it's not stipulated in the contract at all
Um, are you winning son? Yeah, we defeated the enemy of the puzzle game, which is actually a really good game recommend
Say strong reeflings. Don't give her ideas. The zeroes will play for 40 hours straight. Stop. What if a zero plays the league on that? No
Yeah, she's gonna spank him
I stayed up past my bedtime to watch so the
the fun
As in your adult working bedtime
Not child bedtime
Right
Is there a fucking answer are you about to get yeeted?
Okay, proud of you son. A lot of the girls will play the game. Yes, they will. I'm gonna ask them to
Whoa, strongy you could be a healer
Honestly, well, I have the one
That goes in the back door. You know how there's like those those pink ones
That go in the clam. I don't have that one
I have the other one and I think I think I can get you guys to control it sometimes
I need to I need to invest them again
um
Self-establish. Yeah, I stayed up past my sleep schedule. Okay. Okay. Don't give us a heart attack. Thank you very much
Thank you very much. Don't give me a heart attack like that again
I was like, uh
Well, let's catch the word but no, okay. We're good. We're good
I can no longer think coherently
We may also have a sponsorship actually on the video again that is not for
Oops
Should have said no
It was your day, uh, polgis champus. Oh, I just hit my face on the make
I don't know if you heard that but the make just hit my face. I'm getting abused. Um
I are you squiddin me right now
Well, you can
Anonymous says joining your very first spansley stream has to be you using the dull color. It's not here yet
It's taking it sweet as saying
The thing is I managed to get it changed. So don't worry
Don't worry again here. Why is the thumbnail wrong? Bro? I don't everyone sees it wrong but I see it right on mine
Don't matter if you
It's right on my end. I don't know why
I mean, I could I'm just gonna change it
Well, I say the word change it's no the word body changes that
Right, let's get this freaking thumbnail sort of do
Big boom that was me that was me that wasn't you that was my computer not yours not your computer was my computer
All right, I have
Okay, I've saved it does the thumbnail look correct to you guys
If it wants to save
Oh, I'm just just broken my youtube account. Why not all because I want to make the thumbnail accurate to the game
Huh, what is going on with you right now? Please identify yourself
I'm loading save
I don't know what's going on my youtube. It's really oh it changed. Okay. That's good. That's good. All right. All right. All right
All right, my baby don't mess around because of them
Right, I'm ready. I'm gonna go I'm gonna go
You have to understand
Are you gonna have collapse with other girls on patreon outside the agency?
No, it's not planned at the moment. It's very difficult to plan and all honestly
Um, hi strunny. You're my perfect woman. You're really further woman. Oh, no. I'm not I'm not like in a bad way you mean like
You mean like you want hypnotized kind of way, right?
No for me it's still the old thumbnail
Right I go and I'll rest and then I'll grab a bath
And then I'll work and then I'll have more ASMR up and I'm uploading the pre-muffet chair
Said the word out loud. Sorry, uh the the quickly
challenge
audio on patreon
I freaking said the word out loud. I'm not supposed to okay
I'm gonna get going I'll add timestamps for any vod watchers because I've been trying to be good to go back and add
Timestamps because obviously I do pre-game yeah for them post-game yeah
But yeah, quickly challenged. Yeah, basically quickly challenge
Uh, we're playing roller coaster tycoon tomorrow. I don't know if we can get through the campaign
I can't recall how long the campaign is but it'll be interesting
I'm not gonna build a roller coaster though because I don't know how to do it
Okay
I'll see you goofy gobers tomorrow. Thank you so much. Shibi got home an hour ago
I'll need to send her a message to make sure she's all hydrated because you get really dehydrated on planes apparently
But thank you so much for the longer stream as weird calling a forever stream a longer stream lies
Lies, it's not a long stream
But as I said the endurance picks up again next week not this week next week
I'm gonna also put up the rest of my weight rooms as well because they're all lurking in the shadows
But yes, I see you goofy gobers tomorrow. I love you and I give you a bit
That's right. I caught you by surprise
I didn't even let you pick her up
Mmm
Did you like that?
I see you tomorrow. Please enjoy vea and as always
I'm not the streamer. I'm redirecting into I don't know their comfort level. So please be respectful. Yeah, okay
I'm roller coaster tycoon tomorrow. We love it. We can push out of wizard bunny game